the u.s navy
apparently patented or this doctor
patented
what they call ufo fusion energy
and there's also technology that can
engineer the fabric
of reality now we did a bonus segment
over at timcast.com talking about this
for members only
but we do have someone here who can help
talk to us about some of this tech some
of what the government has done
and so we'll get into a lot of this
there's a lot of interesting questions
about how it is that someone comes out
and claims they have
say potentially warp drive like you know
sci-fi technology
and it could be really simple it could
be the us government stole it
and now they're putting it out there as
if they did invent it and that's why
we're getting this breakthrough it's
just
leaking of enemy technology well in this
vein
there is a new cold war now i kind of
wish there was i'm kind of just framing
it that way
but the us is interested in super
soldiers there was a program where they
were working on exo suits iron man suits
and as we know because this news broke a
few months ago china has actually been
genetically engineering
people to make them super soldiers those
are very serious topics and we have some
less serious topics we'll talk about
later tonight and some kind of messed up
stuff there's another big breaking story
where some kid
apparently was doing a prank i'm doing
air quotes right now for those i can't
see
where he walked up to a bunch of people
with butcher knives
in nashville and do you have any idea
what happened yeah the dude
pulled out his gun and fatally shot the
kid because you don't approach someone
with a butcher knife
so we'll we'll definitely talk about
this and a bunch of other crazy stories
we're being joined today by
none other than the alien scientist mr
alien scientist you want to introduce
yourself
yeah my name is jeremy and uh jeremy
risks and i'm from
mansfield mass i grew up in uh
southeastern massachusetts i lived in
boston for a couple years
and now i'm kind of living in rhode
island what do you what do you do you
were talking to us about crazy
technology you you you you named
15 elements in a row just for me to like
prove you knew your elements
right so i i'm i'm got a degree in
physics i went to uh
you know state university in uh
massachusetts and
i've always been interested in science
since like i was in high school i think
i read a book by
richard feynman called uh surely you're
joking mr fineman
and mr feynman uh as richard feynman was
like probably one of the greatest
physicists
ever he was recruited out of mit at age
18 to go work on the manhattan project
so it got me really interested in
physics and like classified programs and
classified physics research and just
like the idea that you know
there's smart people out there that know
stuff that other people don't
but so not only do you have a general
understanding a lot of these stories
about government tech you all you also
seem to be well versed in some of the
more crazy
out there conspiracies too but you seem
to be a bit of a skeptic on that i guess
you want proof everyone likes conspiracy
theories and but you know i like
conspiracy facts i like i like proof you
know i think that there's some value in
you know looking at alternative history
and alternative ways of looking at our
world around us
and i think we you know need to be
open-minded but also
use you know the right tools and have
the right tools but it will be fun to
talk about the
the really kooky conspiracies too just
because they're fun to think about so
we'll do that we'll do that
yeah and how do you and how i think we
can use science to kind of crack through
the layers you know right on right on
we're also joined by the intrepid
t-shirt salesman lukakowski thank you
very much the term cia by the way was
also something fomented by the central
intelligence agenda the term cia
sorry the well the question sorry the
term conspiracy theory
and theorist was fomented by of course
the central intelligence agencies why
would they
pardon me that yes why would they do
that right after the jfk
or the ci i'm just saying it's you know
conspiracy fact which i'm very happy
we're talking about also
with the latest technological
advancement news bitcoin is uh having a
pretty good day to say the least
a lot of people who listened to me a
couple years ago are very happy and
if you want to listen to me check me out
uh by signing up on my email list by
going to
we are change.org in the top right hand
corner and signing up i'm just giving
more from me i'm gonna give a shout out
to max kaiser
because when bitcoin hit like 30k i
tweeted
if you had all listened to max kaiser in
2012 you would all be billionaires right
now
because he was legit it was like you
know you know what 2012 you have bitcoin
at like a dollar
two dollars and max is saying buy
bitcoin buy bitcoin
bitcoins at 47 000 per coin that means
if in 2012
you put in a dollar two dollars or
whatever was trading at five bucks
that would fight five dollar bill eight
years later is is nearly 50 grand
so shout out max has there ever been a
global
commodity that's that's expanded like
that i mean it's a new technology
it's being rapidly adopted so we're
going to get into all that bitcoin stuff
too
but uh ian thanks that reminds me i just
shouted
hey everybody hi ian crossland you know
me and the crypto market's up like 270
billion dollars in the last five days or
something
something i don't know if is elon's um
super bowl
push i heard he did a dogecoin
commercial for the super bowl i don't
know no did he no
no because that was just spectacular i
just tweeted it yeah he tweeted that
picture of him
as that uh that lion king character
holding up simba
and it's him holding up doge oh and he
was like you're welcome
i'm super happy jeremy's here because
there's a lot of complicated technology
we talk about on the show from time to
time and i feel like
we we can only get so far without
actually being scientists so it's nice
to have a scientist
we also have had a bunch of these
stories come out like in december the
super soldiers in china the genetic
engineering
and then we had the story last week
where you know we ended up doing this
members only segment about ufos and this
technology
and so we'll bring in somebody who is
you know you know
looks into this a bit more so uh ian's
here we also have star patch let's press
and all the buttons i am producing over
in the corner pushing buttons
and of course before we get into that
news head over to timcast.com to become
a member
and we have a bunch of members-only
posts now i got to shout something out
there are people who have commented on
these posts saying
why would i become a member when i've
already watched this for free
these these are exclusive members-only
posts so
the videos that are up in the member's
only section you can only watch if
you're a member on the website or i
guess a hacker who's stolen the videos
but good for you if you figured it out i
guess
please don't but uh yeah if you become a
member at tim cass we have exclusive
bonus segments
we're definitely going to have one later
tonight and we set this up as
a shield a safety net the purge is real
it's here they're getting rid of tons of
channels they're nuking people who talk
about
certain issues certainly we talk about
issues that
you know youtube doesn't like and we try
and make sure we do it in a way where we
can
you know kind of get around you know
what they want to you know they want to
nuke you but
we're careful but it'll eventually come
so become a member that way in the event
we do get purged you'll still be able to
find us and it helps support the show
also don't forget to like share
subscribe hit the notification bell and
tell everybody if you really do like
this podcast
uh spread the word it really does help
and also let me add make a comment on
this video
comments help a lot in the algorithm
that's the word on the street
well that's that that's just you know
comment if you want to comment you know
we want that
we don't want to force yourself no we
want we want real people to engage so
love life let's let's check out this
story so so we have this uh uh
update from forbes what is behind the us
navy's
ufo fusion energy patent
now i think when they say ufo and they
show pictures
they're just they're just marketing it
it's it's brand marketing
and like we used a very similar photo
because it's
it's the only way to basically say like
hey here's this technology it's
most reminiscent of ufos you gotta
understand a lot of this talk about ufos
is old talk so what's this new tech
forbes writes when dr salvatore cesar
paez
an aerospace engineer at the naval air
warfare center aircraft division
filed a patent for a plasma compression
fusion device in 2019
it was either a giant breakthrough or
mad science
according to the patent application the
miniature device could contain
and sustain fusion reactions capable of
generating power in the gigawatt
one billion watts or two terawatt one
trillion watts range or more
a large coal plant or mid-sized nuclear
power reactor by comparison produces
energy in the one to two gigawatt range
the revolutionary invention by dr payez
if real
would produce near unlimited clean
energy
from something no larger than a sports
utility vehicle
dr paise's fusion device is among a
handful of outlandish technologies
dubbed
the ufo patents that have in some shape
or form
been pursued by the u.s navy they're
going to mention
that this guy says he's written before
with some skepticism
over dr paez's purported compact fusion
reactor
the physicist appears to have bona fide
credentials including a phd from
carnegie mellon and published some of
his work while much is presumably
classified
he's been employed by by the pentagon
for decades
and this isn't the first patent filed in
his name and all of them appear centered
around what he calls the piezoeffect
dr payas posits that by controlling the
accelerated spin or
vibration of electrically charged matter
high energy electronic electromagnetic
fields
can be produced one proposed use for
such fields is an electromagnetic field
generator
device which would be applied to alter
the trajectory of earth-bound asteroids
over a period of time
while the patent makes clear that such a
device would work only on small
asteroids of under roughly 100 meters
in length or less it isn't hard to grasp
the interest of any defense agency
in providing contingencies for such a
scenario
they say is internal inertial mass
reduction device
is one of the most extraordinary patents
this technology suggests manipulation of
quantum field fluctuations
which could reduce a vehicle's inertial
and gravitational mass
allowing it to travel at hitherto unseen
speeds
the reason the speed of light is
something of a universal speed limit is
that mass increases to infinite
as one reaches it demanding infinite
energy to continue moving
the ability to reduce mass could have
incredible implications for the futures
of space travel
only faster than light speeds of travel
would allow the humanity to allow
humanity to venture outside the solar
system they're going to mention it's got
a high temperature superconductor
and last but not least a high frequency
gravitational wave generator
now all this sounds like magic to be
compliant i'm gonna read through this
and it just sounds
like science fiction but this guy's got
legit credentials
and what other critics have pointed out
is in order to actually get the patents
there has to be a prototype so in some
fashion this guy's had to have proved
he's got this technology
so what does this mean are we looking at
the greatest scientific mind of our
generation
or is this just some crackpot who made a
bunch of crappy patents and then for
some reason someone's rubber stamped
them
i don't know jeremy so it says right in
there in the article by um
it's tyler rogoway and brett tingley of
thedrive.com
they've been doing a lot of great
reporting on some of these you know
technologies that are being declassified
and stuff
this one's a particular interest thing
about the the pays thing right is
what really confuses me is that that
they
i know they've spent more than five
hundred thousand dollars investigating
this that
you know they spent 500 million to build
a railgun for the navy
um if they're really interested in this
technology they're going to be spending
more than a half a million
500 million for a rail gun yes that's
what the railgun that's what the
railguns cost
yeah but is that just like the
government wastes money all the time
you know you know it's it's hard to say
because it's it's
either government is very wasteful as
we've seen with nasa that's
they're buying their rockets from spacex
because the private industry does it
cheaper
um so there's that but there's also
um the issue of subject matter experts
this is how darpa's
tends to do things i was just reading
the book downstairs on the
the brain you know dark pentagon's brain
which is darpa
and the way they do things is they get
subject matter experts or people who are
looking into these kinds of things and
then they give them funding and for
their research and they
that's that's how these projects are
picked up they find guys like pays who
write
he wrote his thesis on this very
interesting thesis paper on bubble
reactions and
and uh you know his theory of warping
space time and so they they funded him
but
i guaran i know that this is not the
only research that's been done in this
the research on this goes back to um the
mid-1990s to a guy named
bernard heisch who worked at caltech
university
and he had a contract with lockheed
martin skunk works to um
and wrote a bunch of papers with um hal
put off and
a number of other gentlemen back in the
uh the late
mid 90s on this sort of space time
metric warping
theory of inertia and of what mass is
and how to get
mass and momentum and how to alter those
things using
refractive indexes of materials and and
stuff like that
so there's been some research going on
to this that goes back
quite a ways that's um less talked about
than than sort of this stuff
so let's just get to the brass taxes is
real
do you think it's real well i don't know
the that if if it was real the us navy
wouldn't put their goods right out there
for us to see they wouldn't just patent
it and
in fact you know they might change a
couple things in the patent to make the
you know technology inoperable or not
give out secrets we have to look at that
part about you know where it said
they got the pan patents granted through
warning of similar chinese advances
and when we look at those similar
chinese advances i i sent you guys two
papers in particular um
on that list that i sent you to to two
of the papers that are written by
chinese universities and a lot of
chinese researchers
on this and it's related to what are
called
optical phenomena and squeeze states um
so they take a parametric a parametric
generator they're oscillated at uh twice
the resonant frequency and it creates
these uh squeezed
states and these so slow down for me
what does that mean so this is this is
uh
this is it what it means is that if we
take a photon plus a photon
the the feynman diagram for for that it
annihilates and that's where we get our
graviton from so
we we know that gravity is an
interaction of of photons
and and the way that photons interact
with matter
and that they're trying to change this
through a warping of uh the refractive
index of
light in the in the around these
materials so trying to make stuff float
there's apparently they can make stuff
float and then there's rumors that this
was reverse engineered from
alien technology that the u.s navy has
had kind of this technology
for years they they didn't know how it
worked because
it's operating on quantum principles and
and quantum mechanics it's not
we can't see it we can't see it this is
something really i want to say something
i was reading once about ufo technology
and about what would happen
if humans actually discovered a flying
saucer in like the 50s
right and they said if you gave i don't
know why they chose this guy christopher
columbus
a nuclear submarine and infinite
resources
they would never figure out how to
reproduce it it's an iphone in rome
yeah the same idea i remember hearing
that kind of conversation on the joe
rogan podcast with bob lazar
and he was specifically talking about
some of the technological advancements
that we're kind of hinting at here
and what you said i was actually
thinking not the smart part but the part
specifically
uh about if the us government had such
technology
why would they release it to the public
it would be counter-intuitive for them
to do this especially if they had
something that was
advanced good useful i think this most
likely in my own personal opinion is a
part of
either one a larger psyop against
countries like china against
countries like russia or two a larger
call for other scientists to come in and
say hey we're working on this this
is what we got what does the scientific
community think about this what's the
reaction can anyone help us
build this because that's essentially
where they want to go in my opinion
this new kind of star wars kind of like
powers and authority
whether it's life speed or lightsabers
whatever it is we have space especially
well they're talking about we don't
swordfight anymore luke
well maybe uh you never know with
technological advancements
we can't even conceive where the
future's going to go
just like christopher columbus couldn't
utilize a nuclear submarine it's the
idea of a cell phone in rome
yeah but they wouldn't be able so so if
if you had a lightsaber and someone else
had a
glock just shoot the guy or the bullets
maybe maybe the lightsaber maybe it's a
lightsaber shield
again we're talking about a lot of
hypothetical stuff but when you look at
the us military they're usually far more
advanced than of course
technology that we know of and they
don't release it they keep it as
close to them as they can because they
use it for war sort of the military it's
like higher tier classified stuff
but but i'll mention there's a funny
scene in the in the movie the men who
stare at goats so luke mentioned the men
who stare at goats
and then i ended up watching the movie
which is more of a comedy than anything
but there's a funny scene where there's
like one dude is talking to his
commanding officer and he's like we
we need to start a psychological or a
psychic
spy unit and he's like why and he's like
well or no no he said was
russia has started doing paranormal
research and psychic spying and he's
like why
because of our attempted our attempts to
telepathically telepathically
communicate with a submarine
and then he was like why did we attempt
to telepathically communicate the
submarine we didn't
it was a rumor created by the french but
the russians think it's real
and i think the story that it's fake is
a is is a lie so they started doing it
so now we need to start doing it to
counter them because they think we're
doing it so now we're actually going to
do it
and then that's the joke of the movie i
guess and it's not even the military
it's a lot of contractors now so
when you look at you know the
military-industrial complex that is the
pretty much the key of private
enterprise that's working in a
quasi-government way just like the
federal reserve is working with all the
big banks
in this kind of quasi way but but in
reality you know there's also
fears of a lot of this technology being
leaked a lot of this technology being
sold to the highest bidder
especially when it's just in contract
and there were fears of that in the
manhattan project too but now now
a 12 year old can go and look up how to
make an atomic bomb that doesn't mean
they could have one though
yes of course why can't he because he
needs
people you need uh oak ridge you need a
uranium refinery or plant you need
resources and the way that the manhattan
project came about they had hundreds of
thousands of people working on it and
and
only i believe a dozen people knew what
was
happening there a lot of people are
saying you know conspiracies aren't true
but but if you look at the way the
manhattan project which by the way was
also forged at the bohemian grove
the way that was kind of created with so
many people involved
not me all these people majority people
not knowing what they were working on
and building this nuclear weapon and and
we
we have to understand we're moving
towards a new technological era
where we're building something that's
going to be way more powerful than
nuclear weapons that's going to have way
more severe of an impact
and the implications here are severe to
say the least when you're talking about
uh refractive index and actually so
talking about the warp drive what
they're building would you call it a
warp drive well that's what i'm talking
about
the warp drive is a good ver a good word
for it but it's kind of like star trek
you know some people call it
anti-gravity so i'm working with a group
right now
um to try to you know bring these
scientists out and bring more
information out of the out of the
woodwork on this because we look at
what's in the public sphere we got sal
pays and him talking about these u.s
navy patents
but i know for a fact that there is more
research that's been done
into this and i have a huge list of
scientists names who have worked on all
kinds of this stuff
so what we've done is we've kind of
created our conference we we actually
got a hold of all these email lists i've
been tracking down these people for the
past decade
and following a lot of their work
because this is what i've been into is
all this type of
research you know where does darpa go to
recruit their next projects out of
there they go to these conferences where
these phds and these scientists go and
present ideas
and then they pick the best ones to fund
and um that's
so i've kind of like gone over a lot of
that research and we got actually all
those darpa email lists
and we just emailed all those people and
we invited them to our own conference
and we started our own conference this
guy tim ventura
american antigravity.com out in
california he kind of got me into
researching anti-gravity back in like
2002
and and i'm now we're working together
to try to we have a conference where
we're actually bringing
people out of the woodwork to come and
talk about what they worked on because
most of it's declassified now or and
it's becoming so
out there and well known and it has such
great implications for the whole future
of our planet that
you know more people are coming out with
it you mentioned something interesting
before we started the show
that you have this guy dr pace or pius
or however you pronounce it
that he's got a bunch of patents that
are kind of all over the place
like an individual would focus on one
specific thing but he's got a bunch of
different things right
right so we consult subject matter
experts because it's the information's
too voluminous for any one person to
have
just massive knowledge of all this stuff
so we consult like people who are really
into a certain subject
but the fact that he published a nuclear
reactor and this space-time warping
thing
condensed matter physics and nuclear
physics it's kind of kind of
gives a hint that it might be technology
that the us navy got through espionage
or some other way right that they have a
secret program building it and they're
using pi s as like the
not the fall guy but basically the
patent funnel leaking it out yeah
but i i would imagine that if this was
developed by
us science of some sort they no longer
need it
they've developed something
substantially more powerful and they're
like okay let's give it to the civilians
and then see what they do with it and
then you know they'll
ramp up production and they'll fix
things or whatever using the patent
itself could we replicate
um if you're saying change the
refractive from what i understand we
talked earlier is you have a material
like a spacecraft
uh hall you hit it with acoustic
vibration and then you hit it with a
laser to change the refractive index of
the material
there's a lot of different experiments
we're trying a lot of different theories
the problem is that you know we have we
have lot
we have almost too many theories at this
point about how it works and and
we're at this kind of standstill in
physics where we we're working with
these
you know quantum gravity researchers
guys who are trying to you know work on
unifying
general relativity and quantum field
theory to create a
theory of everything essentially like
stephen wolfram's doing and some of
these other guys uh
garrett lisi and and uh and eric
weinstein
like those guys working on this yeah
he's
geometric unity theory right really i've
heard yeah
i don't know he presented a whole thing
to the royal society on this
and um and he's no idea he's had
numerous talks with garrett lee there's
a recent one
we're talking about brett weinstein's
brother yeah yeah
uh i'll come up with the word earlier
polytopes and um
like g it's g like subtle geometries
that make up like the core of our
universe you could look up coccidor
dinkin diagrams if you want to get into
some of the stuff
um or or polyhedra polyhedral
combinatorics okay
it's ways that shapes and and different
types of
polygons and things fit together it's
like the subtle innate geometry and they
found that when they when they build
this puzzle of it they create this thing
that very looks very much like particle
physics
and m and m and mimics a lot of these
things but they haven't put all the
pieces together yet
but i want to say that when we do when
we do have a theory of everything we're
going to have
anti-gravity we're going to be able to
understand exactly how gravity works
and so we're going to theory everything
would that allow us to basically build
anything
like if we understand how everything
works we'll know the confines
of the universe we'll be able to just
start and that's the thing that they
talk about with uh jack
so jack filet um did he's a scientist
that's been studying you know
um aliens really for for decades now
and he's come out with this new thing
with a guy named dr gary nolan where
they're actually taking pieces of
alleged
roswell material and these alleged alien
materials that people have recovered or
have
out there i'm sure there's people out
there with these materials
and bringing them to laboratories and
analyzing them with this
approach where they can actually like
look at the isotopes
and what he said is that you know
instead of working with you know 100 and
you know 90 90 something elements like
we work with on our periodic table they
work with all the isotopes of all these
elements in between so they're working
with like 200
puzzle pieces rather than building stuff
with only 90 pieces what would be an
example of an isotope
so an isotope is just so you have atomic
number
that's what goes up on the periodic
table that's the number of protons in
your nucleus
and that gives you your properties of
the charge and the properties of the
atom
then you have something called neutron
number and the neutrons are kind of
stabilize the nucleus
and you can you can kind of like throw a
couple extra neutrons in
and it doesn't change the charge so it
doesn't change the fundamental
properties of the thing it just makes it
a little bit heavier
and when it's a little bit heavier it
spins its quantum spins are a little bit
more slow and sluggish
and so that kind of affects the like
some of the properties of these things
and there's weird things that have
happened like one one of the examples is
they proved that brain our brains
actually work on quantum
phenomena they're quantum phenomenon's
active in our brain because if we give
people
lithium salts but we use a different
isotopic version of lithium
it has a slightly different spin ratio
and it affects people adversely with
their behaviors
and so that proves that there's some
sort some quantum mechanical process in
the brain that's affected by this
different this heavier
spin of the by the quantum behaviors of
these particles and they're even finding
that
birds are able to tell magnetic north
through a molecule called cryptochrome
that exists inside of their their
retinas it's literally a molecule in
their eye
that sense it's super sensitive to these
differences in the spins
and one side will spin differently in a
magnetic field and that's the molecule
that they
they're using that scientists have
identified birds as using
to tell where magnetic fields are so i
want to go back to the
this idea that this one dude shouldn't
know all this stuff
right so and there's more people that do
know it and what we're doing is we we
we set up a conference to kind of bring
these people out of the woodwork and we
say
like look if you know something come to
apec and present
we give you an hour to present your
topic and then we have an hour q a
where we have phds we have darpa people
that show up in our conference and and
cross
analyze and examine these people so it's
kind of like project veritas but for
science
or projects i i like the like the orion
project or the disclosure project but
just for science you know
so but let me ask then do do you think
uh
in your opinion you you know a lot about
the scientists and things they're
working on
do you think that the us and china both
have extremely advanced technology we've
never even conceived of
i don't think we have it yet because the
missing puzzle piece i really see
is kind of like the atomic bomb you
can't build an atomic bomb without you
know
refineries and without centrifuges and
stuff that's why we keep
that's why stuxnet targeted iran and the
thing going on
right now they're center futures right
we're trying to prevent them from the
having the means
oh so this is a bummer you know so well
so i think the material science is not
quite there yet right right right
so that kind of bums me out because i
want to just you know want to believe it
right
but the chinese right the chinese i
think are
significantly more advanced than us in
this area in fact those two patents that
i gave you just shows up how much
research they've been doing into this
um these optical materials and these
meta materials
and um and some of these what what are
they missing and what would they need to
build the machine to produce
this effect i think it's going to take a
consolidated effort
of a lot of different people because
we're going to need material scientists
who are going to take
advice from our physicists who tell them
this is the kind of materials i need
can you make this for me and then we
need the material science
to build those materials and then we
kind of need to
work that out in order to you know
actually do experiments to test
these different effects but um like as
you're saying before about
you know science fiction stuff is is
like quickly becoming reality like all
this comic book stuff from
you know the the 40s and the 50s you
know with captain america the first
super soldier
right basically captain america you read
the book they it's when they discovered
steroids
and they like oh literally a story about
a dude they irradiated and gave steroids
right yes
and they were like the creators that he
was the first super soldier and then you
talk about the
incredible hulk well what was the
incredible hulk you watched the movie
and it's his dad was doing all these
science experiments
he was taking dna and taking little
strips of dna off all these different
animals
like the starfish regeneration thing the
uh these
these exoskeletons and from these crabs
and stuff and
then he injected himself with this thing
and then he accidentally
had a kid and is that the original story
that was well that's the
in the movie that's that was like a 2008
movie i think yeah
yeah but that's what one of the things
is doing no i think you know the
original incredible hulk was when we
discovered uh
we started you know yeah with radiation
and and and radio radioactive waves and
things like that yeah
with gamma gamma waves i think i was
just talking with andreas about
all the um stuff hidden in ducktales in
disney cartoons and stuff
and you know it's it's kind of amazing
when you look back at some some of these
ideas that they had for the future in
science fiction in these comic books
back then like for instance captain
america's shield was made out of
vibe this element and
um you know there's this there's some
kind of
truth to these kinds of things there's
some overlap with stories and i think
that maybe vibranium
might be um might be thallium
it might be um hafnium now
what are those so hafnium is if you look
up the hafnium controversy
you'll find that hafnium can be used to
create gamma-ray lasers and also emp
devices and stuff and there was like
there's some controversy concerning but
captain america's shield absorbs
all of the energy and displaces it
that's like the idea of his shield right
right so that one of the things they did
with hafnium is they
they actually used it in the h-bomb so
one of the guys that was working on that
john wheeler and teller edward teller
they basically
designed the inner core of the h-bomb to
be a half-name
mirror that would basically a gamma ray
laser that would reflect all these rays
back
in on itself like a and that's part of
the um
mechanism for how the hydrogen bomb
worked was uh that it used hafnium in
its construction and that was
that's sort of like a little bit related
because it literally takes all this
energy absorbs it and then releases it
all at once
which is crazy very similar that's like
that's like a black panther suit in the
movie
yeah exactly yeah it's really
interesting looking back at you know
hollywood and entertainment just a few
decades ago trying to kind of
envision what the future is some of them
you know hit the nail on the head to me
in my opinion demolition man got a lot
of things right nailed it
including the calls i think they're the
ones that like first kind of did that
but but
other ones obviously are very wrong i'm
still waiting for the three seashells
though yeah i'm waiting he doesn't know
how to use the seashells i'm waiting for
the cursed machine i mean it's
already in effect somewhat if you if oh
that's really first you get a fine
automatically but then he walks up to it
prints a ticket so he just starts
swearing and then he
rips it and goes to the bathroom with it
yeah if we if we curse we're going to
lose our monetization as well so
uh so there's some other things that you
know are right are right but
from your kind of perspective especially
from your conferences what are some of
the things presented that you saw that
you could speak about that are
truly inspiring or the most eye-opening
to you well hold on let me
rephrase that what was the craziest
that's what i was going to say
i want to see a guy like a lightsaber or
a laser gun and hoverboard what's the
craziest thing you saw presented
ah i mean you could come back to this i
don't know it
has been a lot of good there's been a
lot of interesting presenters but i
think like i almost like feel like the
best is yet to come because
we're the people that really know the
stuff we've had a lot of these guys show
up and they're like look
i worked on a lot of the stuff in
classified programs i can't talk about
what i worked on
but i can sit in the background and say
hot or cold
you know so that's kind of so i remember
when we had uh we saw uh joe rogue had
bob lazar on right yeah
those are not familiar he's this dude
who what was he a contractor right
yes and then he worked at maison physics
facility for a brief time in 81. he said
that he saw like this this like machine
like there's like an object where he
couldn't get his hands like a force
field almost something like that
do you think that guy was telling the
truth well
i've done a lot of investigations into
bob um enough actually a friend of mine
named dan banker
right uh about 50 minutes north of here
in pa he did a lot of
a lot of this research and he's really
good friends with john lear and george
knapp
and all those guys from the original
story and stuff
and the bob lazar case is an interesting
case
but we've done a ton of research on on
it and um
you know we look at the actionable
intelligence and the science and stuff
and you know what we call element 115
and this in sort of our jargon is uh
what's called unobtainium
and unobtainium is like saying that oh
well you can have anti-gravity but
it's this element that can only be
created in supernovas and really really
far
galaxies and we can't create it in our
you know labs and stuff it's basically
saying that yeah you can have
anti-gravity but you need this
high hanging fruit that you'll never
ever reach is kind of the idea with with
that element 115 story
that's what that's that's what he was
saying there's a lot of controversy with
that story they said that he predicted
element 115
it's not that hard to predict higher
elements in the periodic table it's
literally arithmetic you're literally
just adding protons
you know it's anyone who can add so i i
heard that there's uh
i was just writing oh sorry i want to go
back on bob lazar but uh but bob lazar
we'd like to invite bob
actually to apec you know if because
i've never seen bob give an interview
with any scientist he's never given
interviews with physicists it's always
like it always seems like the interviews
he does gives are controlled and all the
questions are pre-screened and stuff
no way joe pre-screened any of that
stuff no that's too much
that's like that's not the kind of first
two hour long conversation no way i had
a lot of people like saying that oh he's
involved with a deal with netflix and
that he's getting paid to promote this
because
let's face it after bob is laura was on
joe rogan his film on netflix got like a
million hits
sure sure but like i know joe there's no
way joe was like here's a list of
like they gave him a list of questions
nah he wouldn't do that i mean even the
best actor would
remember two hours of script but but but
let me just he's been saying it for
30 years no no for sure for sure but
like joe could ask whatever he wants
like but he doesn't know what to ask he
only got into the case recently
but that's that's just a safe interview
for bob then right you know what i mean
like
they put bob in a situation where they
know that joe as a layman is going to
ask only safe questions based on what
he's what he's seeing on the tv
he's really curious that he's he he got
an opportunity
right after he came out in like the
early 90s to present
and before stanford university to a team
of physicists and he turned that down
he also initially said that there was an
alien remember that
his initial story was that he saw an
alien and later said it must have been a
puppet
and i'm like why say that anyway did
they really do that i don't know if i
believe it i feel like they wanted to
feed this guy disinformation they had
him working on like high-tech drones
that they had recovered from tesla tech
or that they'd been working on since
they raided tesla's office
and they invited these scientists in
there like just in case they go rogue
we're going to feed them a bunch of crap
so that they look like idiots we're
going to tell them it came from zeta
reticuli that there's a new element that
you can't find
and that there's aliens involved well
there's lots of theories you know
well like i was just saying in the the
joke from the mendo state goats where
it's like the russians think we did it
because the french started a rumor and
then we denied it but they think we're
lying
it's like with bob lazar he tells the
story
uh those aren't familiar with the story
there's a documentary about it many of
you are probably familiar with joe rogan
and he talked about how he saw all of
this attack this crazy technology
anti-grave saw aliens and then later
said was that maybe a puppet or
something
but many people speculate what if it was
a potemkin research base
that the idea was bring in this
contractor bring in a bunch of them
show them very ridiculous magic tricks
tell them it's real so they believe it
and then wait for one of them to leak it
that way our enemies at the time
russia the soviet union would hear the
u.s has crazy weapons better not attack
them
because they got anti-grav and they're
working with the aliens do you know the
russians
after after bob lazar came out they
spent about
a billion dollars looking into element
115 and trying to create super heavy
elements
the russians did the russians created
element 115. it's called moscovium
right because it was it was discovered
in in moscow what does it
do can it make you it has about a 32
second
uh you know half-life and it decays and
and it doesn't it
there's no stable isotope like bob
claimed yet found
if there is one tomorrow then like you
know but right now we don't but right
now we don't have that
well the u.s government has a long
history of playing psychological tricks
and we'll just think about this on their
scientists that work with them
so the real secrets they wouldn't allow
to leak out okay well depends um
i mean we can't make definitive
statements like that because again
anything's possible right yeah or they
leak it or they or they bury it 30 years
later it would be buried like
i'm just saying disinformation is
something that the us government uses
many times and they steer scientists
tell them they're working on one thing
when they're working on another that's
the manhattan
exactly exactly and it could be that bob
lazar was told certain things that
weren't true
uh but his story was that he was a part
of a team trying to reverse engineer
this alien technology that was given to
them right and
one scientist doesn't do it another
scientist is going to try and they keep
swapping him in him out
that's the story just for he was working
on like eight different craft i think he
said he saw eight different different
shapes of craft right there's a lot of a
lot of there's a big long story there's
a lot of details involved and stuff and
like
like i said we go after actionable
intelligence
the research i did into s4 i found that
there's no evidence of a base at papoose
lake we have the satellite photos of
the facility that's never been touched
um going back
decades so that we haven't found
evidence of a base at papua's lake
but we did find a site for which is that
tonopah test range which is like
literally right next to area 51 so a lot
on a lot of these maps that show like
area 51 and s4
they're really talking about site four
which is at tonopah which is where a ton
of these
you know electronic counter measures and
other technologies were worked on this
is where you know they built the
and flew the f-117 and and the stealth
fighter and the bombers and stuff i saw
i saw a story not that long ago a couple
months ago and it was talking about
these strange
sightings of strange vehicles appearing
near a naval base
and the funny thing was it was like we
you know these soldiers are saying they
see it
and they're they're reporting when
they're doing these training missions
they see these strange craft
and now they're publishing it everyone's
like this is it there's aliens
and then they casually mention in all
these articles that only you know 70
miles away is an advanced naval research
base
and i'm like so what they're saying
they're just well they're just seeing
aircraft made by themselves
is it and they're not they're not high
enough security clearance and know what
it is so they record it
and then why is it that so many higher
ups would dismiss the stories initially
because the stories apparently was that
they were finally now going to take
these claims seriously
in case there's a security threat well
listen if you're higher up
and then you hear a story was like i saw
a crazy vehicle and you're thinking
yourself yeah
the research base is 50 miles away
they're flying something around you
wouldn't care
you'd ignore it that could be a weakness
for us because it really could be an
external threat
so maybe it's good they're actually
looking into it but it also could be
just completely
redundant oh yeah we better investigate
ourselves for the project we're working
is it possible that there are craft that
are so lightweight and that are being
moved around
like by a laser or by a magnet or
something all right so there's lots of
different technologies
there's a guy in from nasa um lightcraft
international he started a company his
name is
leek miraboo it's l-e-i-k-m-y-r-a-b-o
and uh he was working on exactly what
you're talking about um
microwave purple craft where they
actually fire it was called project
skyvault
and they fire microwaves at um beamed
craft
and uh lightcraft and they're able to
like and they develop this into a
technology where they can actually like
blast these um and ionize the air
surfaces flowing across wings of
aircraft so they can literally move the
aircraft and take control of the
aircraft by
like warping the air currents around the
aircraft themselves so they can take
control of like
there's a whole patent we have on taking
control of an enemy aircraft using this
microwave lasers to ionize the gas of
the air going across their wings to to
disrupt its flight and um then also
there's
what are called phase conjugate mirrors
which are really strange
optical property and they have radar
absorbent paint made out of these kinds
of materials in fact like the paint that
they used on the
stealth fighters was actually a meta
material made of barium titanate and
they actually mixed it in the paint so
that it was radar absorbent
and um so that not appear on radar i
thought i thought the goal of stealth
was that it
it looked like a bird right it's that
cross-sectional
they basically the goal is they took
that formula for the cross-sectional
radar
area of of a um object and they figured
out how to minimize
the the parts of it to in that equation
to make things disappear
and uh one of the things that they found
was like that the flat areas
and also they well the v2 was built
actually by
these two german scientists or aviation
guys
um that were working on it uh what were
their names the uh
there was a there was a team of brothers
and they built the flying wing the first
flying wing
is actually like they were calling it
german stealth technology because
actually the stealth was actually a
byproduct it wasn't actually an
intentional part of the design they just
because they built a flying wing it
didn't have that
long fuselage and that long because
that's where the radar was was bouncing
off of on their planes they found
so they did a lot of research into radar
and radar signal returns
and that's a lot of the research that
was actually done out at area 51
and it was headed by the cia on under a
project called project rainbow
which was headed by a guy named edward
mills purcell and edward mills purcell
was
a physicist who won the nobel prize in
the 60s for discovering nuclear magnetic
resonance
and the fact that atoms are are
basically like spinning magnets and they
have resonances and they have
you know different um different
rotations i got to be honest jeremy
you made it an extremely important point
early in the show
and it kind of just uh sucked all the
fun out of it yeah
when you mentioned the need for the
factories to build the nuclear weapons
you know so so i'm not no i'm not i'm
not saying people should build nuclear
weapons let me make my point
you know i said how why can't a
twelve-year-old have a nuclear bomb he
said you gotta have the factories the
refineries
so that means not not it's not
absolutely not necessarily true but
when we're looking for the production of
hovercrafts and ufos and spaceships and
alien tech
you'd see the factories in the industry
you'd see the industrial facilities
you'd recognize them in satellite images
even if they blur them they would still
need way more production
facilities than what we can actually see
i think they're underground
i mean maybe but then it's also the idea
is that
the us has how many factories built
underground to produce this stuff and we
don't see stuff going in or out
like wouldn't we even see where they
were underground they'd have to bring
stuff down there right
i mean we have a massive i mean trillion
dollar military industrial complex
uh you know budget that of course spends
money
absolutely recklessly and there's
trillions of dollars that's missing who
knows i mean i think it's in the realm
of possibility
but going back to world war ii in
germany german scientists were working
on some pretty
crazy radical concepts i i believe
correct me if i'm wrong there was even
an image of a saucer
that german scientists were trying to
configure as a way as to
to make it fly and make it as a flying
object i don't know if you've seen that
but then of course we have to understand
under operation paperclip
a lot of these top nazi you know
scientists a lot of these german world
war ii scientists were particularly
taken
from germany brought into the united
states brought into the cia brought into
the pentagon brought into
uh building the u.s military-industrial
complex didn't we do that with a
japanese research team
what was the name of that japanese
research team that was like torturing
people
you know what i'm talking about oh the
um station
number something or projects something
or something yeah they would put their
arm
outs like into the cold and then while
they were alive and just like watch
their arm
freeze off just really crazy stuff
yeah a lot of the stuff we uh we learned
about hypothermia came from this
japanese research unit that was doing
live human experimentation
creepy stuff man and also the german
scientists that were doing a lot of
experiments on humans too uh
as well i forget the journey and the us
government especially with you know what
we know from acid
and what we don't know from all the
other kind of classified stuff that
still is secret to us 731
yeah 731 that was it um so about the
about the saucer theory about germany so
the germans actually were looking into
uh something called the thule society
and
and the vril yes i remember hearing the
toll society yeah and so the germans had
apparently some kind of top secret
research going on into this
these ideas and of course the germans
were the ones who you know where quantum
mechanics was born
you know it was it was uh of course
discovered in italy the first
sustained nuclear reaction was um done
in italy by enrico fermi
but a lot of the theory was laid down by
german scientists like heisenberg
and um and einstein in fact and uh it's
really um
it really lost hitler the war because he
went after the jewish population because
that drove out
a lot of the most the brilliant
scientific minds of the time
in in germany and caused those people to
come to the us
and when we got einstein and we got
heisenberg it was like
all right it's all it's like we have all
your brain power this is what happens
when you have
an ideology-based society rather than a
merit-based society and i'm mentioning
this because many people say what's
happening right now especially within
the u.s government especially within the
establishment
is pushing uh you know the ideology over
merit that's right and all their best
people are leaving and they're coming to
aipac
and presenting all this information out
to the public but the same thing
happened in germany and and germany lost
people like einstein that of course
decided to flee
rather than of course you know right
that's italian think about this
we did a segment last week on uh male
testosterone dropping
and luke mentioned how in china they're
doing these these training drills to
make their men more manly
you take a look at how china is behaving
and they're very authoritarian
it's it's horrifically nightmarish and
you take a look
it's an extremist ideology as well you
take a look what's going on in the u.s
with the rise of
critical theory and how extreme that is
and
there's probably going to be people who
are in the united states or in china
looking for places to escape to i mean
especially china
i mean they got concentration camps but
even in the u.s we often hear from
people say i'm going to leave i don't
want to stick around
i think we'll actually get to that point
where people are are looking at say
you know joe biden bringing back
critical race theory training programs
that trump try to get rid of
there'll be a lot of people who don't
want to be involved in this they're
going to quit their jobs and start their
own companies or
they're going to want to leave the
country outright right that's when the
u.s will be hit with a brain drain due
to an ideological bent
and people are not comfortable living
under a boot in that way another
like um another dimension of that is on
the internet on social networks you see
people fleeing
social networks that are oppressive and
i i've often wanted to rebrand minds as
a social network for smart people but
bill was like nods too much but we have
to understand
the major epicenters the major kind of
places where people gather to build
stuff major cities
they're absolutely being eviscerated
right now with lockdowns which is
preventing people from
doing business and the people of means
are leaving
yeah i mean this is this is crazy stuff
if it weren't for the lockdowns though
we wouldn't have launched aipac that was
like everyone's home we're all just
waiting to do meetings and that's why we
decided we're going to start our own
like in california the people who are
okay
with what the government has been doing
to them stay and the people who aren't
leave but most importantly
many people who don't like what's going
on and can't leave stay
and then you see joe rogan leave you see
elon musk leave you see ben shapiro
leave
you see the people with the ability to
do so do so quickly
and that means some of the the biggest
industrialists and personalities
will leave under this ideological
oppression california is brain draining
itself of the people who are running big
companies
and now there was a really amazing
segment bill maher did
bill maher this liberal guy with adam
schiff and he's like
look at all the people fleeing he said i
came here in the 80s and i found
paradise
but now i don't know what i'm getting
for my taxes what am i getting
and adam schiff was like well we're
going to make california now here's
here's the kicker
we're kind of we're getting off the
science subject stuff here but david
hogg of
you know the of parkland notoriety i'm
not you know
no disrespect i mean there's a
horrifying event wants to start a pillow
company
to compete with mike lindell who has my
pillow
i i could be wrong about this but my
understanding is that
he's literally calling it our pillow i'm
i know i'm yeah i mean i'm pretty sure
he's calling it our pillow i think he's
too tapped in
but anyway withdrawal he tweeted
something about how
this is crazy he tweeted how we needed
union factory that pays fair wages
and like california is out of the
question yes
who wants to buy a 500 pillow like no
matter how good it is
so so these oppressive and authoritarian
systems
are actually hurting our ability to save
this planet this is the main point i
want to make
how do we get past the problems we're
experiencing today with say global
warming
global warming big big big problem a lot
of people don't believe in it a lot of
people think it's a very serious problem
a lot of politicians will scream and cry
the world is ending and then fly in
private jets and by waterfront property
but in my opinion you know we had dr
chris dr chris martinson right phd
pathologist on
talking about fishery collapse he was
talking about the insect population's
collapsing
whatever you whatever your idea is
there's a delicate balance to this
planet and we are disruptive
here's the problem i see dude i'm all in
favor of solving these problems
but we need to solve it through industry
meritocracy ingenuity etc
when when the left gets ideological and
says
no nuclear energy because nuclear energy
is bad and we're like but that's one of
our best
chances to stop using petroleum they
block us from doing it
yeah because of ideology the dirtiness
of fission
but when you talk about fusion which
gets roped into that same nuclear power
thing and it's really a completely
different process
and maybe you shouldn't even call them
both nuclear though there is nuclear
energy involved i think once we develop
fusion
that's sure because we have all these
ideas about what to clean where to get
the carbon from
what you gotta the ropes you to drag but
we need a power source but look look
even at elon musk with tesla now
becoming
tesla is worth more than all of the next
top 10 auto manufacturers it's amazing
they drove them out of california i mean
here's a guy
who's doing everything they should want
first of all they hate
his guts he's a billionaire and he's a
nasty person i'm like
he just made electric cars cool that's
gonna help the planet right
they don't care because ideology drives
most of these people not all of them but
the ones that are active in the culture
war
and then the the california government
becomes repressive oppressive and
ideological
and then it pushes these people away if
this keeps happening
we won't be able to actually solve these
problems and save the planet through
new technology yeah i mean i i actually
remember seeing that bill maher
clip and i tweeted quote even the guy
who looks like my dad is realizing the
big government is screwing everything
and everyone
now if you look and compare what the
what california is doing to what china's
doing
you know some people are making
parallels that it's almost the same
thing it's not it's completely driven
and when we have societies that are
based on different uh
yeah sorry they're they're they're
there's you know a lot of people like to
say that they're similar they're not
because when you see what's happening in
china
especially with their promotion of
masculinity and then you have chinese
institutions and chinese financial banks
uh financing a lot of the colleges in
the united states they're promoting that
masculinity
is toxic and when you look at this
larger kind of spectrum that's unfolding
here
you see china centralizing a lot of this
for their own personal benefit you see
the united states centralizing it
not for their benefit but for the
benefit of the fuel elite that of course
don't serve everyone else and and
there's a big difference here
with the elites in america also being
the ones that are bankrolling china at
the same time
a lot of people like to post about how
star trek is communism
it's literally not but they don't care
because they're ideologically driven i
mean whatever star trek is it doesn't
really
fit the definitions that we have
historically it's just a sci-fi world of
peace on earth you know not in outer
space but they have replicated
technology and they can their ships
anti-grav and all that stuff and they're
like see that's communism i'm like dude
it's nothing it's star trek it's a
magical universe of fiction
if we want to get to that point it's not
going to be through government
authoritarianism in a command economy
it's going to be through smart people
working really really hard
and people in general coming together to
find new ways to do new things
and unfortunately you know it's
interesting uh ryan long he's the
comedian
he has this new segment out did you you
guys see this he's at the church
the church awoke and he basically is
dressed like
a priest talking about how their new
religion is wokeness
and essentially humorously drawing
parallels between
oppressive religious doctrine and
critical theory
that's the freakiest thing to me that
you've got people on the left
weaponizing critical theory which is a
moral authoritarian dogma
which is going to restrict our ability
to actually develop new technology and
do new things
one of the biggest problems i've always
had with the left because i used to do
fundraising for non-profits
one of them uh i worked for several
environmental non-profits
and i immediately started researching
okay climate change is a problem right
global warming is a problem carbon
emissions all that stuff okay
what's our best solution and it came
across nuclear energy
has zero emissions and it has a massive
energy return on energy invested
thorium reactors yeah i've heard thorium
salts right yeah so they're like they're
very safe they don't melt down
how do they work um there's
i mean i'm not going to get into all the
science of it but but long story short
they're safer they don't melt down it's
liquid right it's a liquid reactor
yeah it's a liquid core reactor there's
a it's it's safer because it
it doesn't you can use the fuel
indefinitely it doesn't have spent fuel
rods so there's not the waste problem
like that
other fuels have like we have at yucca
mountain with uh all the reactor fuel
but so so here i am and it's these exact
environmental organizations saying
no to nuclear energy i didn't know why i
said well
it's zero emission and this new
technology is safe and they're like
nuclear is bad it's bad for the planet
it's the same reason they took
like an mri machine the same way i
talked about edward mills personally
invented nmri nuclear magnetic resonance
so what they use in
an nmri machine an mri machine is called
an
mri machine because they took the n out
it's actually a nuclear magnetic
resonance imaging machine but they
remove the road nuclear because
people hear that word and it's like wow
they don't understand it
but all this is just nuke it's just it's
just the nucleus of an atom it doesn't
mean that it's
it's nuclear uh fission or that it's
nuclear active decay
or radiation it doesn't mean anything
nuclear doesn't mean radiation
it doesn't so do we know do we need like
a uh
atlas shrug type scenario where all the
wealthy
industrialists flee to a secret location
to to be free from the oppressive
government
yes we've had a discussion i think we're
all on board with that
making a ranch where we can build
saucers yes and isn't it kind of sad
that that our resources
our money is being spent for destruction
rather than
building rather than actually
construction if you look at where the
majority of the scientific community
when you look at the majority of the
money that goes into them it goes into
weapons weapons not of course helping
creating solving a lot of the problems
that we all face and we have to keep
all of it the technology secrets
everything has to be not open sourced
everything has to be kept for power
purposes and ego
and uh you know it's it's when we look
at it from
the bigger picture it's absolutely sad
and pathetic they got to be 30 years
ahead
um with what we have publicly you know
they're 30 years advanced in some ways
what's
the classified stuff that's out there
and
they're holding that and withholding it
and using it to make weapons and
they want to keep the the whole goal of
this is you know the military-industrial
banking intelligence petroleum complex
and what is what i call it and it's
basically this organization that
of rich people that want to maintain
power and control
and any under any terms possible they
don't and that includes you know keeping
these technologies under wraps and only
for them and for their purposes
there are few things in this world that
uh
that can break my heart as tremendously
as two specific historical incidents
the first is the burning of the library
of alexandria what a
horror story for human history man that
one just right through the heart huh
one the second though is the quote from
werner von braun
the you know what is he the godfather of
rocketry essentially
and he helped make a bunch of crazy
weapons rocket weapons for uh world war
ii germany
and he has a very famous quote let me
read a little bit they say
when the first v2 hit london von braun
remarked to his colleagues
the rocket worked perfectly except for
landing on the wrong planet
that's so sad man that that that's
that's that's just a punch in the guts
this is a guy who said i want to travel
the stars i want to land on other
planets and rockets can
can do this for us and then a psychopath
took something so beautiful and turned
it into a weapon of mass destruction all
i want is fusion i want working fusion
power i know it's here we have cold
fusion but it's going to create a weapon
it is and it's going to end up being
used to destroy a lot of humans
but what could they do with it if
everyone had one
i don't know focus the energy into a
city so about cold fusion uh
peter hagelstein is a researcher at mit
i went to a cold fusion course there
they had an open iap course where you
could just basically anyone from the
public can go there and go to mit and
take a course on cold fusion
for a week and there's all these
professors and all these students there
and that just
came to show up for the course so i of
course went because i live in
you know i lived close enough to boston
i drove in every day
i actually stayed at my my brothers
lives in boston so i stayed at his house
and uh what what
explain to us fusion and cold fusion
dude so basically the idea is that
you know in regular fusion fusion
happens in a star we have the biggest
fusion reactor in the sky we're trying
to we're wasting tons of money on hot
fusion trying to build these
tokamak reactors and and these fusion
reactors here on you know
what does it do like what is the sun
doing it's literally
what's called you know breaking the
coulomb barrier it's pushing
through gravity and other forces it's
pushing these things so close together
that they get so close that through
quantum like tunneling they think that
they're in the same place and they
actually fuse
so like a hydrogen would come together
and make a helium
two hydrogens will come together the
protons will add and
create two protons in the nucleus they
start hugging each other and then it
creates the next heavy element and then
the next heavier element
and how does that make energy for us
what does it do it's hot so there's a
mass difference between the nucleus
and uh and there's a mass conversion so
some of that mass is
down converted and then the mass the
leftover mass is actually energy through
equals m c squared and that we can
extract that extra energy that that's
left over
through after the fusion reaction so
what do we do we like we end up with
what like it eventually turns to gold so
it will
yeah it will actually in stars the uh
carl sagan is good a book on this the
cosmos if you ever read cosmos by carl
sagan he um talks about this there's a
documentary on it too
where he basically breaks down what
stars do we're we're all star stuff
we're all made out of stardust and
everything that all the atoms in my body
and your body and all the atoms that are
here on this planet
were created in supernovas through uh
nuclear fission
i mean nuclear fusion in stars over
billions of years and
when they basically create the helium
fuse they create
helium then the helium fuses with
another hydrogen and creates lithium the
next heaviest element and it keeps going
up and going up and going lithium solid
solid metal
it's a solid metal yeah it's actually so
when helium is this invisible gas
combines another invisible gas you'll
get a physical piece of metal
yes that's cool um so there's different
theories on what matter is and how
matter is constructed and how matters
made
and um of course you know the alchemists
tried to do you know fusion in their
laboratories to
turn mercury and lead into gold right
and um
the idea is that you know if we can
understand
nuclear science then we can create ways
to trick you know
these atoms into doing these things so
so what is cold fusion then that's like
i hear that's like the holy grail of
energy
right it is it was when it came out with
pawns and fleischmann these two
award-winning electrochemists discovered
this effect
at um you know i think it was brigham
and young university
where they discovered this in utah and
um they weren't sure what to do with the
effect that they discovered they went to
people in their department to try and
you know what do we do because like
we have a new breakthrough energy source
potentially we could get shot by the oil
companies like how do we
get this out and one of the guys at the
department was actually a guy named
steven jones
i know him i spent a long flight from uh
la to australia with him sitting next to
him yeah so
yeah i've met him before too he's an
interesting guy he's got a lot of papers
on muon catalyze fusion and he's got a
lot of
a lot of interesting ideas and stuff but
he yeah so confusion
cold fusion's the one he's that's the
whole history of it but
what essentially they re coined the term
because this press conference blew up in
their face
they had a bunch of caltech and mit guys
come in and say like oh look
this doesn't exist mit basically wrote
the obituary they wrote an obituary for
cold fusion before they had the data and
the results back from their lab but it's
real real cool can you explain what cold
fusion is
it's now called lattice assisted nuclear
reaction
because what they they know is happening
is that inside of a lattice of a metal
these atoms are able to behave
differently than they behave inside
you know a star inside the surface of
the sun where they're fusing so inside
of a metal
you can saturate metal like what they do
is they saturate palladium with tons of
deuterium
the deuterium is like heavy water it's
like you take hydrogen has two isotopes
you add take one hydrogen is just a
proton so if i add a neutron to that
it makes it heavy hydrogen that's called
deuterium if i had two protons that it's
even heavier
neutrons two neutrons and that's called
tritium
right so what they do is they take
deuterium and they pump a ton of it into
this palladium
lattice until they get a saturation of
over 90 percent and then when they hit
that
that saturation point which they proved
the caltech and mit replication
experiments never got up
to that level where they would have even
seen an effect in their labs
but numerous other labs have done this
over the past you know 30 years since
this and have shown positive results and
there's an international collaboration
of scientists still working on cold
fusion and still researching this i got
a question
so we got to keep going on this yeah it
didn't exist
so you put deuterium which is basically
hydrogen with an added neutron so it's
heavier than regular hydrogen yes put it
in a lattice of palladium
yes and then you they because it's
heavier they don't like bounce past each
other they have more of a tendency to
to nail each other when they but what do
you do do you vibrate the palladium to
get them to
to fuse well they found that vibrating
the palladium or
shooting it with a laser and what
something called super waves where they
have um
you know multiple frequencies added on
top of the same wave
when they hit them with these sort of
super frequencies uh called super waves
and
or do laser assisted lattice assisted
nuclear reaction
that it increases the effect so there is
some sort of
what we believe is going on is that
there's some sort of entanglement some
sort of coupling between the atoms
inside this lattice when you get a high
enough concentration and get enough of
them packed in
and that allows for fusion to take place
not only does it allow for it
to take place but it also allows for the
the um the
gamma gammas that should be produced in
these reactions that was one of the
arguments that
these reactions should have produced
gamma rays that should have killed these
scientists if they were actually
producing fusion in the laboratory
but they've shown through moss power
effects and brem strolling radiation
that they're actually able to
divide that energy up and release it as
phonons or electronic vibrations to a
lattice to the lattice so that's
essentially how they convert it into
energy that we can use but we can't use
it because
in order to use energy like that right
in order to build a power plant i have
to make steam that's
what i need so that's how a nuclear
reactor works we we have these controls
oil water
we boil water and then we use that water
to push a tesla turbine
the same technology that tesla invented
so that's crazy phonons to create
piezoelectric uh basically vibrate it
until it creates an electrical charge
it might be a way to do this with cold
fusion where we create smaller voltage
the thing is that we
there there's more research that needs
to be done into turning this into usable
energy because you can build a cold
fusion reactor but if it's cold and it's
not boiling water then you're not going
to be able to produce steam you're not
going to be able to build a power plant
with it but is it it's literally cold
isn't it you can touch it like it's not
hot
it's it's just happening cold is i think
a relative term i i believe it they'd
electrolyze this and um they actually
tried not to
make make it too hot because it will
actually fissure the metal and have
other effects
so it takes place cold yes at a much
colder temperature than
so so wait you're saying that they can
do it but they just can't
convert the energy in any meaningful way
that's one of the biggest problems right
now they're like now what
yeah so now we we've measured you know
the us navy uh spay war lab actually
measured tritium in their
their cold fusion tests the guy gary
larry forcely
and i met him at mit at the at the
conference
too but these guys have proven that you
know fusion's taking place
there's some other process that they
that's not well understood that accounts
for why we don't see these high energy
gammas being produced
but then there's the problem of
engineering a power plant out of it
because
how do you you know how do you boil
water producing phonons
you boil water are the phonons vibrating
the lattice
where the phonons going that it's
producing yeah it's literally it's
relaxing that
um vibration to and then distributing it
to a lattice so it's
divided um yeah it's divided among the
lattice so if we can figure out how to
get
energy from vibrating palladium i i keep
thinking of piezoelectric which is just
energy that you get from movement um
then maybe we could get we could have it
vibrate but is it moving is it really
it really is moving it's really strange
because it occurs at these active sites
and the materials it only
occurs like it um cracks
in metal appear to be like a active site
where these things um
are appearing and then you know there's
different researchers on different sites
one guy's saying though no the cracks
are bad and that's
that's not what's going on and then
there's other guys saying that the
cracks are good
and it's just like ladium's interesting
uh element it's the only element
in the entire periodic table that has
its outermost valence shell saturated
with electrons
so it's like electrically repulsive so
it's probably preventing the gamma
radiation
it's pushing that's got a lot of push to
it that explains why why tony stark
replaced his palladium core or why he
had a palladium core in his
uh his arc reactor that's exactly
exactly very similar to cold fusion in
the arc reactor there's a lot of
similarities between the arc
reactor and coal fusion i'm kind of i'm
joking but like was there is that kind
of the the
inspiration for i don't believe i think
that came
i think that came before of course pawns
and fleischmann iron ban is like the 70s
doesn't it go back no but i mean like in
the modern iterations he's got palladium
in this core then it like generates
electricity of some sort
i'm sure when hollywood was redoing that
film they kind of like they
they consult with people like me because
i've been approached by people in
hollywood like look i'm making a film
and i want like some real science to
kind of like throw in
or something and mix with this that's
realistic and stuff so that happens
i know that happens for sure um so but
you know like i don't know it's it's
weird man so i mean
i can't wait too much but so what we
built we got to build a fusion
functioning fusion generator that
produces electricity
yeah i think these but then i i hear
these crazy conspiracies that oil barons
and you know right the tycoons will come
after them
do you think that's legit like you
mentioned before that there are people
who don't want the system to change
and i hear a lot that's actually a very
left-wing talking point the
environmentalists the climate change
activists say
that it's the big oil companies their
banker buddies and the politicians who
don't want to lose that control over the
people
a little bit more the general idea they
have is that
we as a people are addicted to fossil
fuels
we have built this entire civilization
upon it over the past hundred plus years
and you you hear from people like greta
tunberg who she says you know we
we don't want to wait till 2030 or 2022
we want it now we want a moratorium
and that would mean the millions would
die yeah because they have no food
production they have no vehicles
and so men on the left think it's the
industrialist doing it on purpose
because so long as we're addicted to
this
they can say oh but we can't get rid of
it you'll die mm-hmm
do you think that there's there's like
i've seen so many videos where they're
like i have invented cold fusion or i've
invented infinite energy and they show
like magnets on a wheel spinning and
it's like very ridiculous
but in a more serious tone do you think
that there's prob
there may be scientists who have
developed some maybe you know prominent
renewable type energy or clean energy
that's being suppressed
i'll mention one um you know you
mentioned like
perpetual motion machines i've only seen
one in the literature which
actually might work and it's based on
einstein's brownie in motion
and it's uh i i i that would mean that
more energy is coming out of a system
that was put into it that defies the
laws of physics doesn't it
i sent you a link on it it's it's
basically like it's a quantum effect and
it basically
it exploits the heisenberg uncertainty
principle in
in some ways which is kind of like what
i talk about with these squeeze states
you're squeezing one of those parameters
in the heisenberg uncertainty principle
to make the other one go astronomical so
that you can
you can change its position or its
momentum
in space by by focusing one if you know
one
you can only know the position or the
momentum of an object to within a degree
of h-bar over
two pi that's heisenberg uncertainty
principle so if you know the exact
position
to to within a finer degree of
uncertainty than h bar two pi
automatically the momentum will just go
astronomical just because it has to
conserve this this principle
and the same thing with the momentum if
you know the exact momentum then
suddenly the position changes
so you can never nail down where
anything is in quantum mechanics as soon
as you try to it moves on you
have you ever watched uh who killed the
electric car
yes on the saturn so i think that's what
tim is kind of pointing at
with well the conspiracy conspiracies
there are conspiracies the general
motors streetcar conspiracy was a legit
conspiracy there used to be trolley
systems connecting the entire united
states on the east coast i could take a
trolley from here to new york and
i could pay like a dollar for it but
then they took all the trolleys they
bought out all the trolley systems and
pulled all the cars off the off the
rails
disassembled all the rails all the train
tracks and then no one had any way to
get around so they had to buy cars so
you know i even i i can't get it i can't
even get into the details but i could
vaguely say that i met individuals that
that created
you know innovations and they were
bought out by big companies and they
were told to shut up and they did and
they gave them a big fat paycheck and a
lot of these companies that these new
advancements would contradict with their
market they just got rid of
even solar panels yeah and especially
when you look at something like you know
the the petrol dollar
in its effects on the world stage
involving saudi arabia
i mean saudi arabia is is an empire in
decline
already but if you look at the world
going off oil
they're a country that that again has a
very hard time getting fresh water
have has a very hard time creating any
kind of vegetation any kind of farmland
uh saudi arabia some people speculate
might even have a nuclear weapon already
so when we're seeing empires in decline
um there's a lot of ramifications for
that and that's why there's been
larger theories out there that there is
some kind of bigger conspiracy to make
sure that we stay
on gas that we stay on oil rather than
of course
advance towards uh free energy or free
technology or even innovations
that are less uh you know cost inducive
and don't prop up the saudi empire
the saudis actually have been publishing
a lot of interesting papers uh their
university on on like squeeze states and
meta materials and all this kind of
thing
i looked up the street car conspiracy
and
it's not as crazy as people think it's
semi-debunked it seems based on one
source i'm reading
the general idea was there was a very
aggressive campaign
to buy up street cars and then sell
like automobiles but it was because the
streetcar system was already struggling
and potentially in the verge of collapse
of course
of course how convenient well i mean
look you can choose what you choose what
you want to believe well they could have
kept it but they were like yeah but but
in this larger sphere of conversation
well they wouldn't have been able to buy
them up unless there was
you know there there was a fear that
they were going to go insolvent and so
gm was like now's our chance
so that's what i'm saying me these gm
bottom up yeah so i think that's what
they said uh
general motors yeah let me look yeah gm
and partner companies in grade
engaged uh it in an aggressive campaign
to sell public transport equipment to
companies that were otherwise reluctant
doing this involved buying up electric
trolley operators like a los angeles
railway
they say it was only only feasible
because the streetcar companies
national line city purchased weren't uh
on
bianco points out that this plan
wouldn't have been feasible if the
streetcar companies national city lines
purchased weren't already struggling
so i guess the general idea is the
streetcars were in a state of you know
insolvency
that's allowed auto manufacturers to
come in and displace them and
i mean look at the mta right in new york
city you've got an electric
essentially public transportation system
it's failing it isn't it is indeed the
one in boston too
the t in boston is the same they can't
they can't maintain them and there was
some hope
that amazon coming with this new
headquarters would pump in enough
revenue that they could
shift over to fixing the the subway
system
and then you know there was this big
protest by people like ocasio-cortez
in the financial district which resulted
in amazon saying no that's not a
solution to new york's problems mind you
but they they struggle to fix these
trains so i mean it seems feasible that
the system is just not being maintained
properly it doesn't work
well the empty receives a crap ton of
money we're talking about bridges we're
talking about toll money we're talking
about
some tools in new york city to cross a
bridge cost almost 20 dollars
probably 20 by the making of this video
already last time it was i think 18
to get across the verrazano so we're
seeing a huge mismanagement we're seeing
it poorly run and they're in the deficit
they're in the hole so so like so
i think this more says to something that
that
happens when you have centralization
when you have big government
more than when you would have a free
market but there's also elements of the
free market that we were just talking
about like the electric car
that that get bought up and get shut
down which is which is
which sucks because they buy all the
copyrights uh i i gotta tell you as an
owner of electric car
there are pros and cons i mean when
we're looking at
local grocery store shopping it's
wonderful you just drive there you drive
back i never i look at the gas stations
and i like hahahaha the silly peasants
and their gas stations
and then it's like oh we need to drive
an hour oh my car can't make it
i have to go home and take the gas
vehicle there's pros and cons you know
are they like suppressing solar
technology could you have like really
really good solar panels if
if they were allowed you mentioned solar
earlier as being suppressed
um well yeah they're going back to the
70s as was a technology like
you know even when solar panels came out
they were people they were paying people
off to lie about the efficiency of them
like you know not to so that other
people wouldn't go off the grid because
the electric companies would go out of
business
did you know that jimmy carter put solar
panels on the white house roof and that
yeah george bush removed them the next
year when reagan took off did you hear
the story there was a guy who had a
truck
and he layered it with solar panels and
made it charge and then run on solar
panels and then it can't like to i guess
the i don't want to name the
which company because i could be wrong
they like came and seized it
sheriff showed up and took it away and
said you can't do this there's a lot of
stories like that you guys know stanley
meyer
he he invented a car in the 70s that ran
off of water we have all the stanley
meyer patents and we have a cut we have
a group
and our team working on like some of
that technology
so this is so frozen it's a water car
that would use electrolysis to separate
hydrogen oxygen from water and then burn
that as fuel
it uses a yeah like a nuclear catalyst
to help with the the splitting of the
water molecules so it's kind of like
the the idea is that it it uses it gets
more energy
out than it puts in actually somehow but
it doesn't that's not true i think it's
retrieving energy from the vacuum you're
taking energy from
the environment somewhere there's no
free lunch i don't think
you know i've never seen any free lunch
energy can't be correct but does the
water car actually work
i mean i've seen videos and i think from
a layman's point of view i just read
something on it seems to make sense but
i don't know anything about it
not as far as we haven't built one that
works we haven't you know gotten
a group out there that works and
obviously if it was such a great idea
back in the 70s with these you know
ultra efficient carburetors and all this
this this stuff you hear about it's like
why isn't it why isn't it being done
more today you know didn't they buy
someone bought his patent and then he
died shortly thereafter is that the
story
well the idea is that like the patent
office is sort of like this
trap it's it's like as soon as you
patent something it's it's like
it gets bought out or it goes on a shelf
and then like
i don't know it's it's kind of a weird
thing it's kind of like this this
trap for people that are greedy and want
to make money off these inventions and
stuff
so there's a lot of controversy about
the patent you're big on open sourcing
information right yeah that's been
pretty much your ethos yes
i wanna i don't believe in patents i
don't believe in like i believe in
intellectual property like you have your
your own ideas and your own uh your own
thoughts but there should be a different
system about how we make money off that
and how we
you know control over that because it's
it's really not beneficial to the
species you know
the way things are set up like that you
know i want to mention something about
the streetcar conspiracy stuff
i don't trust the media especially when
you know what
doesn't gm own nbc or something
whoa or or not gm i'm probably i'm
probably confusing things but
when you have i'll put it very simply
regardless of who owns what
when you have a car company that sell
advertisements to a media company
and then the boss of the media company
says look we run the story
we lose a major advertiser i've seen it
happen i've seen it i've seen it happen
so i'm not saying i know exactly what
for but if you come to me and say that
automobile companies
you know work together to corrupt and
destroy street cars and systems like
that
i i want to believe it because because i
think it it's
it's it's completely feasible and when i
hear stories where they're like well you
know the streetcars were doing bad you
guys all had that reaction like yeah
like we believe the media
oh you know oh these big industrialists
are all benefiting from the
the dissolution of public interest
interests and publicly available
transport
let's just believe the mainstream media
in this one no but
i i will point out the same time for me
it is kind of a coin toss because the
mta is collapsing government can't
really run this properly
well there are some good points that you
did bring up though with that because
you know you have to look at the time
period that those rail systems were
built
and the metallurgy that existed at the
time and it's not you know to think that
it's not hard to believe that
those things were a rust bucket by the
time this this actually happened
because we didn't have the metallurgy to
really you know prevent against that all
the steel things that we could make
was very you know limited so like it
probably rusted really quickly
you know one of one of the issues is for
chicago for places like new york i know
this in chicago
people complain that the fare is too
high
but clearly it's not high enough to
actually sustain the system itself
so it's heavily subsidized by the
taxpayer and that's still not enough
but they were they were talking about
shutting down the was it what was it
look the l train
in new york um for con for construction
yeah because
that way they did i thought they'd do
repairs on it yeah yeah yeah much needed
repairs to fix this train
that goes it goes under the the which
river the the hudson river
no no the east river uh it goes from
manhattan to brooklyn
yeah so you had all this williamsburg
property skyrocketing and value
then they announced several years ago
they're like what was it 2019 or
something they were going to shut it
down
for a very long time not just for a few
weeks not just for a few months it
already is barely running
as is there's already major problems
with it i mean a lot of the
you know systems are dilapidated and
there's entire industries
and entire real estate markets connected
to it that almost went out of business
but i think they announced that they're
not going to be taking it out that
they're going to be yeah
and they stopped the construction when
they announced that they were going to
suspend for like a couple years the l
train to fix it because it's in
disrepair
the people who owned the real estate
start freaking out because
who wants to live in williamsburg if you
can't get to manhattan
you take the g train down south to like
what like the ac train
then go to the financial district for
those that aren't familiar with new york
it is
not fun to have one train that takes
five minutes to jump
from from brooklyn straight to manhattan
you have to take
a one train way far south for like 30
minutes and hop on a different train and
take in the financial district then hop
on like the queue will
enter the r up transportation is a huge
huge
problem for globally not just in new
york uh
transportation not a problem anymore
covet lockdowns have made it so
everybody works from home
yeah but also
[Laughter]
happy i'm not so no one needs warp drive
now yeah we can all just work
with that's what we need is warping no
what's going to happen is we're all
going to have virtual
virtual digital spaces i'm wondering if
that's what warp drive is
i want to talk real real quick i
remember
uh to to mention greta tunberg again she
said
it's it's it's insane to think there's
infinite economic growth
and what she doesn't understand is
digital spaces because i remember the
time
when she was saying this like i remember
the first time i heard her talking about
it
infinite economic growth i was playing
some golf game on my phone
where you like you know pull your finger
back and then he hits the little golf
ball and falls in the hole
and there were power-ups you could buy
and i was like when i buy that power-up
literally nothing is produced it's just
a code changes from yes to no
and then you know a zero to a one and
then all of a sudden i get to use the
super
golf swing but that dude still gets a
dollar and then he can spend that dollar
on whatever
so yes if we start moving into virtual
environments
second life type things there can be
theoretically infinite
economic growth because you you buy
digital things
that's what like makeup companies are
taking a huge hit because nobody's going
out anymore i think they're one of the
big big
so they're like trying to merge into
digital makeup and dig you know like
that kind of
instagram filters yeah they haven't
gotten to that business but yeah they
are life on the pods going to be great
you know there's going to be bugs to eat
intravenously and we're just what kind
of bugs
um crickets cockroaches
i think they're very abundant i think
the you know filet mignon steaks are
only going to be for the super uber
billionaire elites and we're going to be
very comfy in our little
matrix battery uh compartments you're
going to live in the pod
and you're going to eat bugs but you're
going to be in the matrix flying around
on a dragon throwing fireballs
you're going to be neural linked to the
back of your head oh now we're talking
just like uh
the matrix baby yeah seriously i got a
question jeremy assuming that we have
infinite power if we can tap fusion
how do we build a warp drive
well you just need the right type of
non-linear optical materials on the
surface of your craft i'd say some wave
guides maybe some
monatomic elements the idea is to create
a meta surface or a meta atom we're
called meta atoms or meta surfaces it's
basically like
you have a surface of all these atoms
and you get them condensed to the same
wavelength through what's called light
matter coupling
and when you couple light or couple
light with itself you can create
these condensed matter states and then
you can get the entire craft to act like
a single atom and if it acts like a
single atom then you can
you influence it with quantum mechanical
behaviors and quantum mechanical
properties
that's kind of one idea you know
something really crazy about star trek
they have warp drive like that's that
this is so this idea of warp drive
what was it first in first contact uh
warp
drive was created by a character named
zephyr real life i know i know but in
real life
let's talk about star trek in real life
when was the first idea of like warp
drive
it was a long long time ago like
einstein
um the first person actually was a guy
named alcubierre who was a scientist a
theoretical physicist who studied like
einstein in general relativity and he
watched star trek and was a fan of star
trek and so he wrote a paper called
really alcohol star trek was the first
like star trek inspired it
inspired the idea of warp drive it did
yeah in the original star trek they had
warp
they did yes because they they gene
roddenberry got the download somewhere
man that guy was talking to aliens or
something
that dude is plugged in here's what
people don't realize even
in even in star trek where they have
warp 9
you know and they can travel much faster
than the speed of light they can
barely get anywhere within the
our own galaxy so people like you know i
don't think people realize
the vast space between galaxies
and even between quadrants of our own
galaxy
traveling at the speed of light so i
think it's a
voyager right this is the series where
they get
transported to the to like a different
quadrant and it would take them 70 years
traveling at their fastest speed to make
it back to earth
and they're traveling substantially
faster than light that's how big the
galaxy is
let alone going to a different galaxy
warp drive is like just a stepping stone
towards a greater
field warp drive or something where you
can
one of the weirdest things right is this
something called quantum non-locality
in physics and this sort of
reinterpretation of quantum mechanics
that was uh
done by john archibald wheeler who
worked with einstein and and he also was
employed by
one of these big companies that i want
to mention and talk about because we
talk about
scientific conspiracies and weighted
ways that they suppress scientific
information
did you know that there's a company that
runs and manages all of our science
national labs they run
lawrence livermore labs national uh
you know oak ridge they they run uh los
alamos
and the company that manages them all is
called battelle memorial institute
they were founded in like the 1930 in
1938 i believe
um and they were founded by a guy who is
an iron metallurgist
and and their metal their company that
specifies in metallurgy and how to make
metals
um and they're experts in you know all
different types of alloys and metals
and they're right in columbus ohio and
this is
sort of like and they control all of our
labs they manage
all of them they're manager so basically
all the research that goes on in our our
labs
they can they can decide what gets
canned and what what gets funded and
what you know if anything gets
discovered at a lab it goes up to their
management chain and of course
they're right there to scoop it all up
do you think that uh
if someone did discover a
rapidly renewable let's not even say
like perpetual motion right this idea
that you can get energy
more energy out than you could put in
let's say they actually discover
something that just uses say
ambient energy in a very simple way that
produces rap like a
massive amount of clean energy do you
think that they would suppress it out of
fear could destabilize the economy
or or just suppress it in general
absolutely why why would they
why would they historically they've done
that with every single technology and
new breakthrough even
even when the russians discovered that
you know the guy who flung the wingnut
off of a thing and noticed that it was
spinning in air and would change
directions
oh in space the russians kept that
classified that effect
yeah yeah so if you have like a t-shaped
object right yeah
and you spin it it'll eventually start
flipping back and forth
right in a really weird way they wrote a
paper on it the russians wrote a paper
on it about a couple years later called
the tenant they called it the tennis
racket effect and they never talked
about you know
this this incident on the space station
and you know you know one of my
favorite stories is i don't know if this
is true there's a meme that goes around
where it's like
the united states spent you know 40
million dollars develop
developing a pen that could write in
zero g the russians used a pencil
and everyone laughs right yeah you've
seen that thing now there's another
that goes around where someone responded
saying using a pencil is extremely
dangerous because it creates particulate
matter that can get into the instruments
and into the air and it floats around
aimlessly so using a pencil is actually
a bad idea getting an ink pen
that can work and is self-pressurized is
actually much smarter
and then it's like it's one of those
things where you you think haha it is so
dumb why are people so dumb they should
use a pencil
but it's only because you don't
understand anything about space or
technology or the physics that you
assume
and that's that's a really good like way
to understand
everything in our society from politics
to science
in that so many people who have no idea
what they're talking about
will push things that will make
everything worse and then mock those who
are actually trying to solve the problem
and there's also what we find is like
there's a ton of people just
filling filling the thing with mud
they're filling the the thing with those
perpetual motion machines and those
magnetic motors and all these other
things
and it's just basically a perpetual time
wasting machine it's what i call it
i love watching the perpetual motion
machines because
most of the time you can tell you can
see where they hid the battery
yeah to make it spin and then other
times it's like
even if that really was you'll see like
really clever ones i'm like how do you
get energy out of that
yeah i mean it's like okay you found a
way to make the marble go tick tick tick
tick you know down the slope
and then it goes up and goes again are
you gonna somehow turn that into a
generator
is there it's some way that the marble
moving in a circle is gonna
spin a turbine i guess maybe a little
tiny mode or get a little bit no it just
never happens
you know what i love those when people
talk about magnets and they're like why
don't you just have a wheel with a bunch
of magnets on it
so that when the wheel comes around the
magnet pushes it and it just keeps
getting pushed forever and i'm like
because the magnets are pushing and
pulling
so it just stops have you ever actually
tried it it's fake it's not real
so you asked me before about who i
thought was like the weirdest guy that
we've ever had come on and present
or like most interesting so i i thought
of like two probably examples
um you know you mentioned high frequency
gravitational waves that was mentioned
in that thing
we actually had a guy named gary
stevenson from darpa who came on
and uh presented on high frequency
gravitational waves and and their
generation
and he talked about this um we talked a
little bit about that nazi bell the
rotating mercury plasma and these these
torus drives
so like we found out that general
electric actually did some experiments
on
on a patent that was patented by an
engineer and valley forge pa named
henry william wallace and it was on this
gravido magnetic effect or
kinemasic field and they literally
ge was taking like tocomoc reactors and
and rotating mercury mixed with like
cesium barium and these other elements
to try and test these torsion field
theories of like
of this physics and stuff and we have
papers on it from like these guys going
back to
you know talking about rotating
superconductors in these magnetic fields
and stuff um one of the other guys that
presented was a guy named alzafon
who did some of these research
experiments for boeing back in the 80s
and
1981 it was a paper that was written and
we're trying to replicate that
experiment in our lab right now that's
kind of where we're at i think that was
like the turning point
where our scientists in you know 1981
when they did this boeing experiment
with alzafon on nuclear magnetic
resonance
i think that was the turning point when
they realized that this that the spins
of these atomic molecules and the
elements that are in the atoms is really
like key to how this effect works um
because that was where they first came
up with
a realistic theory for it this guy um
alzafon and then
he got funding actually from boeing to
do this research and it was classified
for years
until like we found it through you know
a couple years back through our research
and now we're actually putting this
together on a tabletop lab experiment to
run it ourselves
and we also got his son he's of course
passed away sadly but uh
his son is still alive and had a lot of
his dad's research and we actually
interviewed his son on apec and and got
him to present a whole bunch of cool
stuff
so you mentioned the column effect um
coulomb
and that's when so they're spinning the
atoms are spinning they come together
and because of this coulomb effect they
spin into each other basically and then
start to spin as one and that's what
fusion is
well the coulomb barrier that's the cool
fusion is breaking the coulomb barrier
and the coulomb was a as a was a french
scientist who
the father of electromagnetism and
charge he's the first person to isolate
and
identify electric charge and um did a
lot of the experiments
you know to set the foundations for you
know electromagnetism which of course
was picked up by you know heavyside
gibbs maxwell and those guys who
formalized it into a a field theory
where they could use you know into a
mathematical field theory
which is really um some of the you know
the foundational points of where all
this stuff comes from that was
a guy named coulomb that's that's where
this comes from because he he's like the
father of electric charge
he proposed like a barrier an
electromagnetic barrier that atoms
couldn't
couldn't pass through because the
electrons are pushing themselves away or
something it's because they're
their neutrons make the atoms heavier
that they're able to
there's a strong nuclear force which
holds the um which holds these
sub-atomic elements together that's our
our current model so some of these
models that we're looking at or deal
with
knots this uh this theor this
mathematician named louis kaufman who
does a lot of uh work on
knots and he thinks that matter is
actually light that's twisted up in
knots
and and depending on how much how tight
and how big those knots are will depend
on what the matter is
so he says that you know like this is
just a simple knot hydrogen is just
a super simple knot it's just you know
when you create one proton but when you
start weaving these things together
they have to have these other elements
in there to hold the knots together and
those elements are actually neutrons
and um it's so it's it's there's a
mathematical core theory behind you know
this this image that you get of just
these balls
these colored balls like neutrons are
protons are red and neutrons are green
and they stick together and
you know that's our our model but that's
not really realistically what is going
on on that quantum level it's more like
knots and twisting of fields in in on
themselves and around each other
in different geometries this is some
crazy stuff but i think we got a bunch
of people listening who want to ask some
questions so we'll go to super chats
absolutely if you haven't already smash
the like button
like subscribe share all that good stuff
notification bell and become a member at
timcast.com because we will have a bonus
segment up a members-only
piece of content after the show just for
those who are members to help make sure
that we don't get completely annihilated
if we ever do get banned but let's read
some of these super chats and again make
sure you smash that like button can i
plug uh
alienscientist.com and also my youtube
channel is alien scientist on youtube
we're uh we're trying to break a hundred
thousand subscribers and if you guys can
help that happen that would be awesome
we're almost there all right we got some
super chats from people and these are
these are probably
from uh remnants from other episodes
carl flynn says tim crew
served means exactly that a weapon
operated by a team
vice and individual the term can apply
to anything from an mmg to a howitzer
interesting david young says referring
to how to fix things and create culture
get involved with big brothers big
sisters org or get involved with local
orphanages
children are our most precious commodity
and it takes all of you
i mean literally with no kids there's no
civilization it's us
it's people you know slanty chauffeur
bear says temple of nine muses
library of alexandria burned 47 bc
defunded 215 a.d
war looted 275 a.d and 295 a.d
destroyed in an earthquake 365 a.d the
mythical 391 a.d
burning is a con conflagration with the
demolition of the shrine of serapis
interesting thank you yeah thank you for
that
grab boyd biden says i have been rocking
out to tom mcdonald all night
also played will the people i want to
know why it doesn't have 10 million
views um
well i think will the people to be
completely honest is just not
a the kind of pop music that typically
would get
a million views you know there are some
songs that are very serious
and don't do that well in there some
songs that are very like
orchestrated very well to put it simply
depends on what you define as a good
song
is a good song a song that people will
want to share and listen to over and
over again
because if that's your definition will
the people probably ain't it if your
definition of a good song
is something that has meaning and is you
know just
makes you feel good it makes you want to
listen and make sure to play it then it
probably is
but certainly it's not uh not for most
people i don't know i kind of disagree i
think it's a pop hit
we just don't have a marketing firm like
b was a bgm
um getting it onto all the radio
stations syndicated across the country
yet if we get on the radio stations
you'll see
there there are a ton of songs that
look if the song was good enough people
would have shared it that's that's all
that matters but we don't have radio
presence yet
that's that's that's not what i mean i
mean look there are there are a lot of
songs that shouldn't be popular i mean i
remember growing listen to nickelback
and i'm like they just put that on the
radio why it's not even good music
i'm not trying to mean a nickelback but
you know i don't like it like you're
self-managed
yeah but listen if the song was truly
good people would be sharing it and then
it would take off
that's just how it works like look at
gangnam style yeah you know it was it
it still was clever marketing but once
people saw it everybody kept sharing it
because the song was fun and funny and
people liked
doing the horse riding dance dance dance
video
oh yeah yeah yeah march of of you know
execution or whatever okay
all right here we go ks says peter
schiff believes that bitcoin
is a bubble that will eventually burst
like the fiat usd will
it would be cool to hear him and uh and
andreas debate whether gold or d5 will
be the new usd
it'd be cool to have peter schiff on to
talk about uh bitcoin especially as
we're looking at it nearing
50 000 yeah
geez i i i you know what i'm so i feel
bad for some of my friends
because i know a lot of people i
messaged you know a year ago
bitcoin was at like what like seven
grand or something and i got friends
and i got a lot of friends who who have
money to invest and i said just put it
on bitcoin buy a bunch of bitcoin right
now and they were like well i don't know
we'll see and i'm like listen i'm
looking at what's going on
in this world and i'm telling you by
bitcoin and they just didn't want to do
it
yeah last year bitcoin was around five
thousand dollars
10x basically yeah and there's a lot of
people i mean uh peter schiff really
doesn't like bitcoin there's a lot of
people saying
uh let's check in on peter schiff make
cert make sure he's okay
because before like he was wrong
on so many of these issues we have we
have we got a good one right here
evan g d says dr steven greer has been
going live on clubhouse and sharing his
knowledge of anti-gravity et crafts they
are not
nuclear look into it very interesting um
i would invite stephen greer to uh come
on our show and talk to our team of
physicists about that and see what they
have to say
because uh i think we have the subject
matter experts beyond what stephen greer
has because i know who's on his team and
i know who's on my team
justin asks for the alien scientist do
you believe bob lazar's story and do you
believe dr steven greer
or are both bs artists
i think a lot of the stuff that's that's
mainstream is
off point um of course i don't think
like
they're going to dangle the most popular
stuff like my my channel has been like
super shadow band
like i've never been able to reach those
types of audiences this is like my first
breakthrough of actually having
you know a large audience so i i mean
the thing with bob lazar is that we
invite him to come on and present
and we have so many other physicists
with so much real actionable
intelligence that we can actually build
and test in our laboratory unlike the
element 115 stuff that's
you know it's it's what's there what's
there for us to look at
really i it's a story and uh it's an
interesting fascinating story it got me
it got me interested in this watching
bob lazar and unsolved mysteries back in
the 90s
getting getting these ideas of these
seeds playing in your head is there
you know government research being done
on aliens or is there a secret base
you know where they've had these things
and sort of my research going through
that has led me to some
fascinating discoveries which are you
know
quite interesting um like for instance
you know the roswell stuff did you know
that the
allegedly the roswell material went to
wright-patterson air force base after it
was flown to fort worth they did this
raimi memo with the they posed in a
press conference room with a weather
balloon
and then apparently the real material
went to wright-patterson air force base
and was
studying in an underground facility at
wright-patterson apparently they had
like a whole
underground lab that was underground
city essentially built at
wright-patterson in the 40s when they
first built wright patterson airfield
and that they were doing research on
this and that's what led me to battelle
because battelle is literally 65 miles
away from dayton ohio in columbus ohio
they were the top metallurgists and the
one of the top military
industrial contractors at the time um
they would have been the perfect place
they would be the only place that i
would have sent medals for analysis if i
was
you know the military back then you know
if i was the air force that's first
place i would have sent but what's
interesting about patel is that um
we've shown that they run all our
national labs they're also a private
corporation
which makes them inaccessible by foia so
all this research that they've done
going back to 38 you won't be able to
find you won't be able to get with foias
and that's been one of the biggest
problems in ufology is saying
well if this material is real and
roswell is real where the material going
where's the paperwork for it
private companies private companies
there you go we got another one here we
got aaron edwards he says my old
roommate worked for
spa war and darpa we had he had 700
million dollar budgets and darpa have no
budget limit per project
both are part of the doj no budget limit
huh
that's amazing no bid contracts are a
real thing
um liquid logic says tim can you raise
awareness that currently nobel prize
nominee julian assange is being deprived
of his winter clothing since october
people should contact governor of hmp
belmarsh prison rob davis
absolutely delta sly says we need to
re-pursue the research of lab-grown
brain organoids and understanding the
conscious
without moral ethical restrictions
kind of with you on that one i don't
know one thing that bob lazar didn't
talk about about
area 51 was these things called foggles
apparently this this is a real thing
that when you're outside on base at
these
secret facilities you have to wear these
uh goggles on your head which limit your
vision so you can't even see 20 feet in
front of you everything's blurred out
apparently they use these on on like
pilots and stuff
one of the guys who first guy who talked
about that was actually a friend of mine
when i started getting into this i um
back in like 2004
i watched this documentary by this guy
named edgar fouche i'm talking about
you know he worked at area 51 and i made
a bunch of
videos on this and i started talking
about it and a guy who knew him actually
put me in touch with this guy who was a
former area 51 employee out at the base
and i became friends with him and worked
like kind of i talked to him like every
day for like a period of like five six
years with this guy ed fouche but he was
the first person to talk about meta
materials and quasi crystals
being part of this research and that was
back in 1998 before like
anyone was talking about these materials
which is super fascinating
so i started researching meta materials
and you know of course you find out that
they're used for invisibility still
stealth and cloaking technology which
why wouldn't they be interested in that
that's an obvious one but then the other
thing with these quasi crystals these
aperiodic
crystals and veritasium channel did a
thing on those aperiodic tilings and
showed how
you know these symmetries they're
they're like things that you look at
them up close and they don't have any
symmetry but you zoom way out and they
suddenly have these symmetries
and they're they're very interesting one
the guy the guy who won the nobel prize
for quasi crystals is a is a guy from
israel's technion university named
daniel schechtman
and after he graduated with his material
science degree from technion
he went and did a postdoc at
wright-patterson air force base
very interesting now we got james that a
14 year old but the nuclear reactor in
their garage in new york
google it i heard about that yeah we've
heard about that we got
we got to invest in these young kids man
all those new billionaires that got a
bunch of money in bitcoin
there's this is lots of opportunity to
become trillionaires
the first person that does asteroid
mining is going to become the world's
first trillionaire and that's what we
need to move towards because that's
what's going to
launch us to support post-scarcity
society that we're trying to get to
where we don't have money anywhere we
don't have like there's no concept of
that
in the in the future in the star trek
society anyways there's no need for
politicians either we need to get rid of
politicians
all together pseudo agree with that
pseudoscience said yeah
pseudoscience says hey guys scientist
here in industrial science companies
file patents because attack will become
or is already well known
this allows them to sue for infringement
otherwise you'd keep it a secret
yup johnny arson with a more pessimistic
and sad
comment says the universe hasn't
contacted us for a reason my guess
we are an invasive species they dumped
us here earth is our prison
johnny universe talking about a negative
nancy there he has
his prison planet this is your contact
right allowed to leave
matt hatter says i looked up the patent
for the inertial mass reduction device
and its design is almost identical in
form and use to the em drive
a sealed conical resonant cavity with
microwave emitters pointed into it
weird coincidence yeah so am drive uh
so there's a couple interesting
scientists you could look up uh one's um
woodward the woodward effect um he runs
the estes park conference james woodward
uh
and that's we invited all those guys to
to apec and stuff but also
uh mike mcculloch this uh there's a
company in the uk
uh he's from plymouth university he's
written he's got a quantized inertia.com
and he's got a whole bunch of papers on
there that he's written and he's kind of
going after that m drive thing
and there's a ton of darpa funding for m
drive like we said that there's
we i like i said that five hundred
thousand dollars on pays isn't the only
thing the vm drives are interesting it's
like just a piece of metal
that gets vibrated by what is it
background radiation then it produces
thrust
it's a conical cavity and apparently
this um it's on it's an asymmetric field
that's produced on one side through this
uh through these forces and uh it
creates a push
and you know it gets rid of his theories
get rid of the
the need for dark matter it gets rid of
you know um dark matter
it explains it as something else um dark
matter is kind of an
a very big controversy in physics right
now there's billions of dollars being
put into the
hunt for dark matter to try and you know
discover
where you know prove dark matter is real
the only thing we've gotten close was uh
you know the nobel prize was given out
for this
gravitational lensing apparently from
dark matter and stuff but i still have
i still don't know that there is a
hardcore proof of dark matter and we've
wasted so much money looking for dark
matter instead of pursuing other
theories like this m drive which could
lead to new propulsion technologies i
got a question for you it's kind of
interesting
as uh someone who doesn't know as much
but i read somewhere
something about there should be like an
equal amount of antimatter in the
universe
right yeah that's that kind of idea is
that the dark it's dark matter this is
missing
matter from the puzzle and um is that
what they mean by dark matter with
antimatter
antimatter and dark matter are different
this goes back to you know dirac
uh what dirac called dirac holes he
it's basically a missing point in the in
the physics and in the equations and he
he was the first person actually predict
dark antimatter sorry antimatter
before it was discovered but we we have
discovered antimatter and it's sort of
like a fact of nature that you know we
have all these particles and each
particle has
its own antiparticle as well that exists
and so there's
been a lot of experiments with
antimatter uh there's a guy named daniel
kaplan who's doing some research into
muonium which is anti-muons and uh
exotic atom that forms with an anti-muon
and an electron
it creates an a like a what's almost
like an atom it's like it's like a
proton
but instead of the nucleus being a
proton it's actually an anti-muon
and it kind of has these its own weird
properties but they're trying to produce
these and see if they actually fall up
in a vacuum because they still don't
know whether antimatter falls up or down
but they predict that it will fall down
interesting all right we got timothy
may says would you please ask him about
water purification using
electromagnetism
soft destable ionic bonds stuck on
filtration
working on it since 2003 yeah i'm in new
mexico with beef with los angeles
los alamos labs ask him if he's ever
heard of uh
shungite it was a material that was
discovered i think by um
henry the great or i was one of these um
guys over and there was a deposit of
this material called shungite
and they would use it for water
purification like the army was using
their our military was using this
material that they'd mine and using it
for water purification
they actually found out the the shungite
contained fullerenes
which are you know bucky balls or bucky
tubes yeah interesting
and that's why it had the such amazing
water filtration properties but there's
a number of companies working on this
including uh
justin tipping hall right in connecticut
um of nano holdings and nano holdings
are working on a lot of water filtration
technologies and stuff like that so
we have a very good super chat from
sequoia tenebres who said truck driver
here
plenty of secret government facilities
around the country both above and below
and they are very selective of which of
which of
us deliver uh of which of us deliver and
we have a code of silence with locations
this is the hold up on
on ai trucks interesting
i believe this that makes a lot of sense
and i want to believe it because i want
to believe that there's more out there
and life isn't so boring there's more
out there you ever see those
submarines that like go under they'll
come in the coast and then they'll just
go into the coast like going out so i
got an interesting
um tunnel conspiracy theory that i'm
trying to investigate right now i've
been going off about the right state
tunnels
right state so wright state is a
university that was built right next to
right the original wright patterson air
force base before the new
wright-patterson air force's
base was built up north but apparently
there's a whole tunnel system that
connects all the buildings there's 1.8
miles of tunnels that connect all the
buildings under wright state university
and there's conspiracy theories that go
around with all the students there that
say that there's aliens down there that
these tunnels were used for
government research into aliens and
stuff which is kind of interesting
because uh the first the first building
that was built according to the
sites right wright state university's
official website is actually called
alien hall a allen hall a-l-l-y-n
alien hall which is kind of i thought
was an interesting play on words
but um according to their official story
these were hvac tunnels underneath the
school that they had
that they remodeled into pedestrian
tunnels but i don't understand why they
need hvac tunnels big enough to drive a
car through
it doesn't make a lot of sense to me and
there's a lot of theories that this was
part of an
old facility and that you know that
there's a wall behind the wall
so we're kind of want to do an
investigation like one of those ufo
hunters shows where we go to wright
state and see if there's indeed you know
there's
something hidden in those tunnels under
there that's a crap ton of tunnels that
the united states government was
building because of the cold war so they
exist
and i'd imagine that i'd imagine you
know
the reality is they're doing research
topical research we know the manhattan
project was real
and they're researching weapons aliens
is a good cover it makes it sound crazy
it makes people think ah you're nuts and
they disregard it
and then you don't really know what
they're working on right they they said
a lot of the ufos were
stories were spread there's a movie
called miragemen which actually takes
the position that
most of the ufos and alien stories were
actually spread by the cia to
cover up um the technologies that they
were working on so that a sense
people see this craft flying around
they're like aliens what better way to
to hide it
bruno rodriguez says physicist i want
bob lazar to be interviewed by a real
scientist me
take my money yeah i agree jensen zager
says
as said in archer you think there's
problems in the middle east now wait
until the oil is useless
oh yeah yeah i was hinting at that uh
especially when i was talking about
saudi arabia in the petrodollar it's
coming and it's going to get
nasty i want to protect those people i'm
obsessed with building like
solar-powered water condensation around
the desert like our military i think we
should use it to
to build water for other countries saudi
arabia is trying to transition from an
oil economy to our tourism tech economy
and it's not working
and it's not going to work yeah listen
i'm not trying to be mean or anything
but there's some civil rights issues
yeah
yeah it's not uh lgbtq friendly so
very interesting bring this up we have a
super chip from robert miller who said
saudi arabia is massively investing in
green technology
so that's actually a bad example since
they clearly see the handwriting on the
wall and are making massive investments
in green
like i said saudi arabia's university
over there has some
really interesting papers and a whole
team that's working on
like these nanotechnologies and and this
kind of stuff these photonic materials
where they are in the world they're
screwed as soon as people stop buying
their oil they're screwed yeah it's
going to get
more so adrienne says tim keanu reeves
in a movie called chain reaction
he was hunted by oil tycoons for using
hydrogen fusion to replace fossil fuels
i remember that movie
it was like a murder and then he's like
on the run he's on a motorcycle and
stuff
all right let's see uh what else do we
have here
john doe says some scientists found an
application for graphene
where they were able to generate
electricity by harnessing free energy
could this be combined with cold fusion
to generate electricity instead
see science daily for an article i think
the silence daily article you're talking
about is either magic angle
graphing and there's a couple other
applications of graphene where they
they create graphene sandwiches where
they put like a layer of superconductor
between two layers of graphene
or they put a layer of a different type
of material between two layers of
graphene and there's a lot perovskites
that's the other one that they've done
they prelay or perovskite so there's a
lot of interesting research
a perovskite is well it's a german i'm
not in russian
uh term for a um it's a it's a type of
um
it's a type of material that conducts
protons um and
and and produces uh it has a strange
quantum behaviors and quantum effects
and all right we got this from the scot
16 it says the highest level conspiracy
theory
every single conspiracy theory that we
know or will know are false because we
are allowed to know them
den every single one dj
medero says the german brothers we named
horton
yeah they were the builders of the goth
229 flying wing design
the operation to steal the nazi
scientist was uh was codenamed paperclip
ps became a tim cast patron last month
do you mean a member at timcast.com
i i have a defunct patreon you guys
shouldn't use it
and do not be confused if you uh pay for
this channel i think people can donate
to this channel right monthly and become
like a
paid subscriber no tim oh no okay yeah
yeah let's go tim cast actually people
were doing that and thought they were
signing up for the website hey you know
before we go to the next chat you
mentioned alcubierre warp drive earlier
yeah
and then you you start talking about uh
patel did they suppress
his warp drive technology in the 50s uh
so this was in the 1970s because it was
after star trek was 19 like 60
you know i think 68 or 69 or what i
don't remember the
when star trek started so this was this
was 1970s that al kubir published that
paper
it was not suppressed in fact nasa
sonny white of nasa's advanced concepts
research office like he's been writing
papers on this and he's actually been
presenting it
at like estes park in a lot of these
other conferences and has a lot of work
that nasa's doing on this with the um
i think it's the starship program the
there's there's a program that they're
working on at with nasa
um right now with sunny sunny white is
the guy's name harold white
and uh so so no it hasn't been
suppressed um
it's not just not talked about the part
that has been suppressed
is the material science and how to
actually achieve it so the theoretic
part is fine
but when you're talking about actually
building it and doing it that part is
suppressed
so that would that would belong to a guy
named john archibald wheeler who we
talked about
who who had written a lot of stuff with
einstein and and stuff and wheeler did a
lot of classified work for patel we have
his fbi file it's quite interesting
he actually left a he actually left a
whole notebook
full of all of our h-bomb secrets on a
train one time
wow mark all right we got to go in here
paul look it says but yeah he was
involved in squeezed light research we
just found out recently back in 1985
the the stuff that um university of
rochester is doing with uh
what's called uh polariton condensates
or or surface plasmon polaritons that's
the research you can look up we got one
from paul luckett he says propulsion is
only one small part of the space travel
problem
we need huge advancements in every other
area of spaceship design
the human body doesn't do very well in
space for extended periods
yep i've been thinking a lot about
having a lot of drones you know how
birds fly in a flock together and you
can build drones to kind of do the same
thing where they all move in tandem they
can like create shapes
in space with little laser like things
so they can all work together build
giant craft at once
we have a very important super chat yeah
i have to read it sorry if i'm
interrupting but
jonathan muntz says my grandfather was a
top judge for the air force at wright
patterson
in charge of contract negotiations what
questions should i ask he is dying
do you have an email oh please email the
alien scientist at gmail.com
like get in touch with me i would i'll
come out there and interview because i'm
going out to wright state soon i'm going
out to ohio to go do this investigation
of the tunnel system and i would love to
meet up with you and
and and get that and that's jonathan
muntz
absolutely awesome that's that's great
al says aliens took over the government
why do you think they want everyone to
do
butt swaps
they don't have to abduct anyone for it
anymore so
in china you heard that right
interesting theory
wow here's a good one will dawson says
hey i watched your video about tb12 and
kaepernick great video kaepernick was
ruined by chip kelly in 2015-16 nfl
seasons
tom brady is the undisputed goat there
we go
level 99 mastermind says we did it lads
florida man was caught at the super bowl
was it the guy who like put his pulled
his pants down and was running around
you see that onesie yeah yeah yeah yeah
this is cool john wright says hey guys i
live in eastern washington and the
history of the manhattan project is
really interesting
if you ever head out this way uh if you
ever head out this way
to your the b reactor b reactor let me
know
you can use my land as a base that's
cool hey
we're looking for a place to host a
ranch and then you know start
a project to move to we can all like
work on this together i've been
seeing a lot of people have been talking
about this idea for a while a
grassroots effort to actually pull
people together and build stuff
we have a couple labs right now working
with a lot i'm probably going to stop in
new jersey on the way back
to our falcon labs um with our my friend
mark
and do some more research on this al
zaphon experiment we're building at that
lab currently
but uh we're definitely trying to get
hooked up with more researchers more
labs more scientists who are passionate
about this and interested in in pursuing
this type of technology
and that's definitely something we
should talk about
charlie in charge says the akashic
records is the name of the theorized
force that people like tesla tap into
for their huge leaps in knowledge
i highly recommend recommend learning
about it as it's really
it's a really interesting topic have you
guys ever heard of that yes
i don't know much about it but that's
gene roddenberry maybe tapped into that
too
and yeah the kashic records yeah it's
like when if we talk about this
the other night on the bonus segment how
like god or whatever that
light energy is we're transmitting
energy to it and that it's trying to
transmit energy to us but we're like
having a hard time receiving it usually
we're like desensitized but if you can
somehow receive that
energy that information that it can
write information in your brain maybe
this one oh god that's kind of reminds
me of this
idea of you know that's kind of what i
do with alien scientists the idea behind
an alien scientist is that i
created this idea of something it's kind
of like what i call channeling you know
where we say like we're gonna
we're gonna envision i'm gonna channel
this god and i'm gonna vicariously live
through my this god through myself and
and that gives you god-like powers
because you're able to start
putting your mind in a different sort of
a way of thinking about things so this
is way
this is like a practice that i i do a
lot with uh trying to you know envision
what aliens
are thinking how their physics works and
and it's it's definitely i definitely
gotten some downloads in my dreams i
must say i
in fact i got one a couple weeks ago
that was pretty pretty intense
we talked about it all right we got will
will billy the hillbilly says
what do you think of graphene is it a
over hyped technology or is it the
future magic material
graphene is certainly um a magic
material carbon is
is very interesting there's a lot of
other interesting materials though we're
talking about so like
um one is uh i put a link in the in that
list i gave you was called hydro dicarb
hydrodicarbine it's basically like a
3d printable diamond that they're able
to they can actually 3d print
diamond um is that what they do there's
like neon gas
it's uh it's it's like a liquid poly
it's like a liquid polymer that actually
hardens
of some kind it's just it's like the the
diamonds dissolved in this other
carrying agent and then that that
evaporates and it leaves behind this
crystal structure that forms in a
diamond somehow
um that's an interesting technology uh
but again that there's
lots of other materials out there not
just graphing uh one of the ones
is metallic glass or amorphous metals
that's another really interesting one
they're basically it's a glass is formed
by like things that cool too it doesn't
actually harden into a crystal
so when you cool things really quickly
it doesn't get to crystallize it just
forms this
amorphous blob of and that turns out
that it has
really interesting properties for these
materials so these metallic glasses
there's a whole video on on metallic
glass they're doing laser etching and
polishing of it to create these you know
surfaces which are
amiable to the the environments so they
they basically they can actually make
this stuff hydrophobic and hydrophilic
by etching it with lasers
just by changing like these micros of
the nanosurface structure of these
materials
it actually changes the physical
properties and gives them completely
different properties
what happens if it's hydrophobic and
hydrophilic what does that mean exactly
so it's it's like um water pulls up on
it and goes off it or
like you can actually like put it on it
doesn't get wet you can put it under
water
and pull it out um i think i'm not
exactly sure
what the full the difference is between
hydrophilic and hydrophobic
um one one one holds the water and one's
rejects the water
so it could either absorb or reject the
water does it it's like a hydrophobic
surface the water just bounces off yeah
and hydrogen
does that mean it absorbs uh imagine i
don't know
i'm not a subject matter expert on this
i kind of just i dabble in a lot of
stuff so
italic glass can you allow metallic
glass with graphene one of the
interesting things one of
the the main major marcel the main guy
from roswell
okay on his deathbed and and in a 1985
interview he said that
it wasn't a weather balloon it was a
material that he couldn't bend or break
that they could fold it up into a ball
and then let it go on the table and it
would uncrinkle itself and fold itself
out
mirror smooth again now we have no of no
such material like that but the closest
thing that we have currently
is metallic glass because it has this
ability like it's like
saying it would fold and hold memory
foil the memory foil
from from roswell there's a bunch of
people who describe this metal and a
bunch of people even material scientists
from wright patterson who said that they
worked on this type of material even a
guy from the u.s navy who said he had a
piece of this in his laboratory so they
they tried to drill through it
and they couldn't drill through it with
the carbide bit they wouldn't even drill
through this
this thin foil material and the only way
you can think of we have
stuff like this we have uncuttable
materials and the way that we build
those is they actually heat up the blade
and destroy the blade before it destroys
the material
it heats it it like it does an action
where it will heat up so hot that it
will destroy the blade
so that you won't be able to cut it
because it destroys your blade yeah
um interesting stuff but that's the
closest thing we have right now so it's
not just graphing there's a lot of
materials out there
here we go titan tech says hey tim been
watching for a while
normally i love the political content
but this content is way more interesting
makes me forget about all the awful
stuff going on these days
this was ian's episode i certainly think
so he's jeremy
ian's the guy that got me here though
really yeah i've had the fortune of
working with jeremy for like two two and
a half years now i've been watching
your stuff like on youtube since 2010
when you started talking about quasi
crystals i really that that perk my ears
up and realizing well okay
if we're really gonna focus on solutions
this is the way to go it's the science
here we go yvonne lee says interesting
show tonight ian was like a nerd in a
nerd store loved it
jeremy anyone told you you look like
pablo schreiber
never heard that one before i heard fox
mulder i've heard the scout from team
fortress 2.
yeah there you go
[Laughter]
he definitely does all right let's just
we'll grab one more right here
maybe maybe one more we'll see sudo sign
says great show
one more thing most tech and chemical
companies ask you to sign
over rights to patents made under their
employ sucks but yeah
definitely yeah like microsoft and a lot
of these companies they say like
apple was one of them they said like you
know whatever you invent
while you're an employee of us uh is a
result of the you know
intellectual experiences that you gain
through being access to our great
company and so we own anything that you
invest that's like even if you go home
at the end of the day and write
something in your basement they still
want that if you're employed
yep yep all right here we'll do one more
storm man says tim world war one was not
started for what think
it was started to put the world into oil
because it was cheap
world war one also stopped all research
on free energy
is that true they stopped energy free
energy research no there's
lots of free energy research going on
and then goes i've seen all those
all those youtube videos where the guy
has the
what's that thing called where it's like
they're jars with liquid in it and then
the wheel spins and the
the the water drops and then it makes
the weight you know what i mean you know
what i'm talking about
yes yeah oh yeah so those things that's
not that's not real though i imagine
right
i've never seen one that that works
if they got one that's real there was
one one interesting video i watched a
long time ago
where it was actually i think from an
honest person where they were explaining
how to create
a air perpetual motion but what they
said was it simply worked by absorbing
sunlight
and then you know heating and cooling
metal so one side would
you know become lighter or hotter
because of the sunlight the other side
would go into a shaded area
based on the way that they built it and
that could actually make movement but
they were like basically just made a
really crappy solar wheel
when you talk about um light matter
coupling what do you think
photosynthesis is yeah plants
eaten at some point it's plants doing
this all right
okay so we make machines that can do
that they're already making
artificial leaves they're already making
sure we have solar panels
you know yeah so we have solutions you
talked about using magnesium
as the body of a craft potentially and
that's the
that's the atom that's at the center of
every chlorophyll molecule we talk about
magnesium yeah magnesium is an
interesting thing it's uh no what is it
what not magnesium it's bismuth actually
bismuth is uh that has the highest
diamagnetism it's like the highest spin
of any um of any element and so
if we're kind of like you kind of think
of it as like a pendulum or a flywheel
in this material and if we get a sheet
of this bismuth
because it has this highest diamagnetism
it's really great to build wave guides
out of this material because it's
it it reacts so quickly and so readily
to spin more
fast more quickly than any other element
on the periodic table
so not magnesium i don't know but they
had magnesium layers so they had
they had this layer of metamaterial
apparently that was given to
um it was came from arts parts this came
from like art bell on coast to coast he
had gotten like material sent to him by
viewers at coast to coast where like
look i have pieces of roswell debris let
me send it to you so if anybody has
pieces of roswell debris that they can
legally
send me po box on the website i think
we'll figure it out why so apparently
jack valet
jack valet has some pieces of this stuff
and that's what he brought to gary
nolan's lab
and is doing tests on and stuff and
apparently they had
some of this material and the
destructive analysis doesn't work if you
were talking about an atomically
structured material that's made out of
like that's made on the atomic level
like these uh we're talking about
photonic crystals and photonic circuits
this is where we're going
technologically with uh with our
electronics currently is is
bridging what's called the the terahertz
gap so there's actually a gap in the
electromagnetic spectrum that we can't
really interact with and it's called the
terahertz gap
and it's on the level of wavelengths
that are where matter is
and what matter what the wavelengths
that correspond to the sizes of
of material objects of all the
interesting all the elements on this
table
and when we once we do that it's called
it's going to be like a merger of
electronics with uh photonics and
there's going to be
there's going to be a replacement of all
our technology we're not going to be
using
electronic devices we're going to be
using more um
quantum based devices that rely on
photonic effects in fact there's already
electric microphones in your cell phone
in your cell phone it has an electric
microphone the microphone in your cell
phone
works on on this sort of like more solid
state physics technology as opposed to
the the old-school condenser microphones
that we're
working through here which are older
technology so you
know very very interesting just to wrap
it around you had a bismuth layer but a
magnesium layer underneath yes so that
material so that material back to that
material from
the art bell stuff so they sent this
material apparently to the us
army for and got uh this crada agreement
with the us army
where they sent this material off for
analysis and supposedly the u.s army is
going to tell us stuff about it
but they have pictures of this material
and it's got they show us the micron
layer of of this and it's magnesium
layers and bismuth layers
in this material with monatomic iridium
i guess on the very surface
and that's sort of a material we're
interested in trying to attempt to
create
looking at different manufacturers that
can create this material so that we
could test in our lab
but again i don't know you know if that
is really alien technology or an alien
metal that would be super interesting
and i'm definitely
interested in studying that kind of
stuff well jeremy looking into it you
know
this is uh a lot of people that chat are
like tim's trying so hard to end the
podcast
thanks for hanging out you said a lot of
words i didn't understand and that's
kind of the point
um i think i i grasped enough of it i
think we had a pretty good conversation
so thanks for hanging out
for those are listening smash that like
button on your way out go to timcast.com
become a member and we will have
a bonus segment coming up so thank you
all so much you can follow me on
instagram twitter mines at tim cast
my other youtube channels are
youtube.com timcast youtube.comcastnews
we are live monday through friday at 8
pm
and uh again teamcast.com become a
member jeremy is there anything you want
to mention
yeah if you're interested in the science
you go to alienscientist.com youtube
alien scientist
also american anti-gravity dot com um
that's we're working with uh tim we have
a conference coming up this weekend
we're going to have a guy from
boeing and we're going to have a guy
from airbus on to talk about their
research into antigravity
wow so cool it's it's it's happening bro
we're getting more people
emboldening them letting them it's okay
to come out of the woodwork it's okay
to to release this to the public now
it's been better hands with the public
than it it could ever be with the
corrupt
horrible politicians that are in control
right now right on you know even though
i didn't understand the majority of what
you said it's very refreshing to have
this conversation and i'm happy we're
talking about
this and not cnn again uh ragging on the
q anon
shaman and his organic food which they
just wrote a piece about right now and
it's frustrating
and it was really interesting and
thought-provoking it was great to see
ian having his moments
and of course thank you guys for joining
us if you want to support me and what i
do you can by purchasing the shirt that
i'm wearing right now
that says fyi the government is way
deadlier than any virus and you can get
that shirt
on the best political shirts dot com i'm
also a youtuber my channel is we are
change and i release videos monday
through friday we are changed to see you
there thanks for having me
i will say luke's shirts are very
comfortable i got one
tested it out is it just teespring i
don't know no we're using uh
another company a guy just messaged me
on instagram he switched and he's like
hey i hear you're getting a lot of your
shirts censored so
all the shirts are back up and all the
crazy ones are coming back
even in the next few days we got some
wild ones coming send my personal thanks
to that guy because his shirts are great
um
we got something we can't even wear on
the show yeah so just saying the bonus
segment
i want to give a special shout out to
graphene my long lost love i will
forever
be 20 29 peak graphene so get ready for
it jeremy thanks so much for coming man
tim
luke lydia i didn't get to mention
quantum radar we'll have to do a bonus
segment
quantum radar is basically like radar
but you entangle your photons so that
you can tell if
you can see invisible things and
apparently the military
there's an article you can look up
called the short life of quantum radar
and it talks about how they built this
system deployed it to the military
and they received too many false
positives so they took it out it was too
good they were like uh okay all right we
just opened up the sky to all the
invisible stuff flying around out there
oh [ __ ] well before i forget let me uh
shout out my uh
ian at ian crossland you can follow me
on youtube facebook twitter
mines and instagram and also on
twitch.tv
it was great to finally meet all you
guys thank you so much for this you guys
rock
and i am sour patch lids you can find me
on twitter and mines and you can find me
at real sour patch lids on gab and
instagram go to timcast.com become a
member if you want to watch more members
only content
it is just you scroll down you go to the
website you scroll down a little bit
says members only there's a bunch of
posts we even have full episodes there's
two full bonus episodes one's an hour
long
talking about religion most are like 10
to 15 minutes but we will have more
coming up soon so we will see you all
there and thank you all so much for
hanging out bye guys
you